e
e e
I can't officially start the meeting
without the sound of the gavl so I had
to get that um so um maybe we can start
with the uh pledge
um uh represent of litfield would you
lead
us FL of the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible liberty
and justice for
all thank you very much and we have um a
number of
bills um to uh exec this morning and
then some hearings this
afternoon um and the uh um first bill um
that we will take up uh this morning is
um House Bill
184 which is establishing a committee to
study changing school start
times um representative litfield did you
have a
motion yes I'd like a to make a motion
of ought to pass please thank you uh um
is there a second I'll second yeah thank
you um and represent McDonald um I think
you had an additional motion yes I move
Amendment
okay this amendment was handed out
yesterday by representative
Terry um I have I have a I have more we
have some more cop
yes
yes we'll just get those
copies
um uh represent McDonald would you like
to speak to uh the amendment sure the
amendment does two things the first is
changes the duties of the committee
because it makes it more investigative
rather than saying what the committee is
supposed to find out before they
actually have the time to investigate
this important issue and the another
thing is it amends section five of the
bill which is the reporting requirements
it says that the Speaker of the House
the president of the Senate as well as
the governor will hear the um report
from the committee as opposed to in the
bill as proposed the governor is not on
that
list uh thank you
um and represent Freeman did you make
the second on that I did make the second
would you like to comment on the
amendment no thank you um Mr chair I I
um Echo the sentiments of uh
representative
McDonald thank you um would anyone else
like to speak to the amendment
representative SEL I'm sorry oh thank
you I just had a question so in the
original bill it talks about the report
goes to the um Speaker of the House the
president of the Senate the house clerk
the governor and the State Library this
amendment keeps the governor but removes
the House and Senate clerks um and my
understanding from the work I did on a
study committee last year is that those
two have to be included but um and so I
just wanted to yeah to clarify I I've
never heard that they have to be
included okay but you
um we can sure make sure that the
speaker does uh send additional copies
out okay I just I just want to make sure
that we're not in a way that would cause
us further yeah difficulties later right
yeah yes representative thank you just
my my question deals with the um line
five of the uh Amendment rep Amendment
um where it's talking about summarizing
evidence-based studies since these the
surveys um a lot of may just be
informational because collecting data
from different schools I'm not sure
they're going to have all going to be
evidence based if we if you went down we
have 10 15 20 people on this committee
if we went to every one of those school
systems they would tell us
informationally what what they've seen
um so I I I don't know how those to Mel
I don't see the survey part is sort of
informational may not be evidence-based
because they think a survey what you do
um but it seems to me when I look at
line five it it restricts that only to
evidence-based studies and I'm not sure
I don't I have no problem adding it in
there but you see what I mean right I I
I think it makes it makes like the
allarm is going to be informational
versus evidence based right I I don't
see a problem um you know with with that
I think um there will also be uh
existing as you indicated um additional
school policies um uh on the subject
taking a look at um uh I I just think
that the um studies that are presented
the uh um the maker of the uh uh
Amendment um wanted those studies to be
uh
evidence-based uh in addition to yeah in
addition to okay right thank you thank
you um yeah I I think we're the
committee is just really um collecting
information um and then it's you know
okay as opposed to the original um bill
which seemed to indicate that we were
supposed to be making a recommendation
or or providing some statutory language
about schools times I think appr I
appreciate that just concerned that we
didn't get that's fine I thank
you yes thank you very much I'm sorry
especially as I'm only just seeing the
amendment today um y the other question
that I have has to do with whether we
should be also incorporating the fact
that we have districts within the state
who've reviewed um this discussion and
made decisions and shouldn't that be
somehow Incorporated that they should be
looking at why District in the state may
have already decided in favor of or
oppose to some I just I'm just concerned
that we're limiting in some capacity by
not talking about local districts rather
than State policies right
I I I don't see any
um drawback to um looking at that I
think um clearly the intent during all
the discussion um was to uh um look at
uh information from um existing
districts that have already studied it
um I know representative McDonald you've
talked about that would you like to
mention yes anything in that regard
actually the reason I support this
amendment is because my district in
Salem that's SAU 57 we had looked at
this because a number of students
including such students like The free
girls K lcer of peterborg that testified
and determined that we were not able to
do this because of bsing and also
because of our CTE Center at the Salem
High School and so I like this amendment
because the result of the committee
could be that it's up to local control
and districts like Salem can't do this
whereas the bill as proposed the duties
make it seem as if the goal of the
committee is to make this possible
everywhere where some communities such
as mine determine that it's not possible
as of now at least it's not
possible thank
you um for the
discussion see
um Madame clerk if you could uh take a
rooll on the amendment which is
0394 motion is ought to
pass Vice chair on the amendment right
yes Vice chairman Noble yes uh
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balboni yes
representative selig yes representative
kuger yes representative Snodgrass yes
and chairman cordelli yes 17 y zero Nays
representative litfield do you have a
further amend excuse me further motion
based on this vote Yes ought to pass as
amended
please seconded by representative
McDonald uh any further discussion
representative
litfield yes thank you uh I'd just like
to applaud representative wheeler for
bringing this to the Forefront this has
been an issue that we've discussed for
many years we had people come and
testify and if I remember correctly we
did not have anyone testify opposed to
this bill I also just wanted to take it
a step further and say that
representative Terry made a point
yesterday of letting us know that he was
in touch with representative wheeler
about this amendment and representative
wheeler was quite comfortable with it
just to alleviate any concerns thank you
yeah thank you for that representative
McDonald anything further oh well said
Thank you thank
you any further comment represent sing
thank you I I would just encourage the
membership of the committee once it's
appointed to take a look at the report
that was provided to the Oyster River
School District I think it's six or
eight years ago you know pandemic time
I'm a little fuzzy on the exact year but
there was a committee that spent two
years doing work on school start times
and presented a very comprehensive
report um headed by Sleep specialist Dr
Rachel higen Botham and I would
encourage them to research that and use
that in their study process great thank
you R litfield thank you would it be
possible for you to facilitate the
committee receiving that information is
that your District it's
my thank you thank
you um further comments I seeing none
Madam clerk if you could call the rooll
on
otpa Vice chairman
Noble yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative baloni yes representative
selig yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes 17 yays zero Nays
thank you
um let's next uh turn our oh yes consent
is okay yeah thank
you uh next turn our attention to House
Bill
394 um which
is um and there is an amendment that I
think you should have gotten this
morning um and this bill is relative to
the powers and duties of Cooperative
School District budget committees and
the role of Cooperative School District
Board member Representatives on such
committees um and I'll turn the gavl
over
to uh representative
Noble and I recognize representative
cordelli for a motion thank you I would
like to move on to
pass this on the the main Bill and then
we'll do the amendment
I'll second that thank
you any discussion from the maker of the
motion I I do have a further Amendment a
motion if I might sure thank you I would
like to move uh to pass on Amendment
H is there a
second represented more second sorry I'm
losing my voice
it'll come back eventually
hopefully representative more
seconds great is there any
discussion repres cordelli thank you um
yes I think that this um Amendment uh
clarifies some of the language um from
the original bill um I see
representative spillsbury here um and
and it's my understanding that uh he
worked with the school boards
Association on some of the language and
um I think that this uh does clarify um
the intent as was discussed in the
original
hearing any comment from the
second you pretty much just summed it
all up
okay and um we have a motion of OTP on
the amendment you want to ask for
further discussion oh I'm sorry is there
any further
discussion representative Hall I just
want to say that I appreciate the
collaboration between the two parties
you know that's a that's a great sign
thank
you any other
discussion seeing
none we have a motion of OTP on
Amendment 20250 0476 H I recognize a
clerk for a roll call okay chair Noble
yes representative dry yes
representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Balon yes representative
selig yes representative kuger yes
representative s grass yes and chairman
cordelli yes 17 y zero
Nays and we're back to the main motion
which is now
otpa I I would like to move uh
otpa uh as the motion based on that last
vote I'll second
that okay any discussion representative
cordelli uh nothing further from
representative Freeman
no thank you madam chair any other
discussion motion is
otpa and recognize the
CK uh representative Noble
yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tzar yes representative
morrris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Co yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
selig yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman
cordelli yes 17 y zero Nays everybody
okay with consent for this great thank
you
uh let's uh next take a look
at uh
uh let me see if it's on
the schedule
um
532 which is
relative
to alternate dispute resolution and
individualized uh Education team
plans um and uh
um let let's hold this for a second
because there is an amendment and I
think I do have copies in the other room
so let's move on to the the next one um
and we'll come back to
um uh let's uh let's look at House Bill
this is requiring certain non-public
schools or education service providers
that accept public funds to perform
background checks on all employees and
volunteers um and uh representative did
you have a motion on this Bill yes I
move in expedient to
legislate thank you is there a second
I'll second that representative
Freeman and representative dry would you
like to uh discuss your motion yes thank
you very much Mr chairman this is a a
repeat bill from last bium and it had
problems then and it has problems now
the biggest problem is that it requires
background checks of private citizens by
private citizens and that makes it very
difficult the private citizens cannot
make background checks on other private
citizens and all the results have to go
to state agencies when home schooling
families become EFA students they their
home education program is terminated but
and they become EFA students this bill
as it's written has um any employ or
volunteer that has in-person instruction
with an EFA student has to have a
background check so there's a lot of
ways that um Home Educators run into
other people who are in person
instruction um including people in
co-ops who are actually regular home
education students who would have to be
um have background checks so there's a
lot of questions this is just a
beginning list was who uh does it
require background checks on everybody
that a home schooling family turned EFA
runs into who pays for them who requests
the checks who would receive the results
who would monitor compliance is there a
penalty for non-compliance that's just
the start of the list of questions I
think this is inexpedient to
legislate second thank you um any
discussion from the secondary for that
motion no thank you Mr chair I I think
representative dry um voiced all of my
concerns with this Bill thank you any
further discussion representative
Cornell yes I agree with the um itl on
this um although I do think that um
people working with students should have
criminal background checks but I I do
agree that it it doesn't work with the
193a homeschool families um which in the
last bill we were supposed to work on it
with them to make sure that this one was
better and we didn't do that so I would
like to see this bill come back in the
future um but with working with those
homeschool families to see that it it it
works for them too so but I do agree
that this bill doesn't work now thank
you further
discussion see none um Madam clerk uh if
you
would Vice chairman Noble
yes representative dry yes
representative Lichfield yes repes oh
representative Freeman thank you yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Corel Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock
no representative Hall yes can hear him
representative bbon yes Representative
selig
no representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes 15 y two
Nays uh is anyone opposed to consent
and wanting to do a Minority Report I
don't think so okay rep c you're
okay so we will put that on on
consent um
represent excuse me uh House Bill
235 is relative to the uh code of
conduct oh 235 I'm sorry May thank you
said yes this is uh relative to the
amending of the educator code of ethics
and code of conduct to include
responsibilities to
parents oh
great thank
you uh
representative dry did you have a motion
possibly yes I would like to move a to
pass thank you very much is there a
second representative Morris thank you
uh representative dry would you like to
speak to your motion yes for the the
time that I've been on this committee I
have heard over and over about the the
three-legged stool for Education which
is parents students and teachers and I
think that that the parents part is
missing from the the the code of conduct
and the code of ethics part in here of
people that we're responsible to and I
would like to include it this bill does
it thank you represent
Morris any comments from anyone else on
the committee on 235 representative
Woodcock thank the chair um I appreciate
the the maker of the Motions uh intent I
think our responsibility is educating is
is to the students and they're our
primary responsibility thank you thank
you uh representative
Boni um yes I will not be voting for The
it um for the OTP on this bill uh
because I believe that um it's already
parents are already included in the code
of conduct under the Community section
and as a representative Woodcock said
the teacher primary responsibility is to
the student uh with consultation with
the parent I mean I think that's already
in there this bill gives no explanation
of how these responsibilities to parents
are going to or or what those
responsibilities will be or how they
will be identified um the previous code
of conduct was put together um it has a
group effort with stakeholders involved
um if you open up the code of conduct it
goes straight back to the rules and
there's no guarantee that there is going
to be that um continued St holder input
in deciding what those responsibilities
are going to be and so for that reason I
will be voting against the OTP thank you
represent Murray thank you Mr chair I
too will be voting against the OTP um in
addition to it already being U mentioned
in the community section of the ethics
guideline it is also noted in 21 N1 uh
that parents are enumerated in statute
within our book so for that reason I
will not be supporting autopass thank
you rep
dry yes and also in the statute 21 thank
you thank you Mr chairman uh also in the
statute it talks about responsibility
students responsibility School Community
doesn't Define what you have to do to do
them parents is just in there it's just
another entity it's got equal treatment
with all the other things that are
mentioned in that
statute further
discussion see none um Madame clerk when
you're ready
this is ought to
pass Vice chairman Noble yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock no
representative Hall no representative
bbon no Representative selig no
Representative kuger no representative
Snodgrass no chairman cordelli yes nine
yay
and eight yeah am I right yes yes thank
you yeah I got to do this
again yeah could you repeat the count
yes
nine nine Ys and eight Nays okay thank
you very
much uh
next let's
um no
reg I had mentioned um house
build 532 two um and uh thanks to uh Gen
4 we now have uh copies which I will
pass out copies of uh an
amendment the
am it's number uh the um the amendment
is
0480 H
Mr chair we would like to clock us for a
few minutes to look at this sure
appreciate the
back that's thank you
Jen this way
yeah um yeah do you want to go into the
office
okay uh you you you can stay we we're I
don't think I don't think our side's
going to Us in here
we'll take a
walk
e
e e
we were all to go okay we'll uh
go back
into did you have to
I we're going to open the executive
session on HB
532 relative to Alternative dispute
resolution and individualized education
plan team meeting facilitation and I Rec
recognize representative cordelli for a
motion yes I would like to move ought to
pass on House Bill
532 is there a second
uh represent Nat
seconds any comments from the maker of
the motion yes I would like to uh offer
an amendment if I
might
sure
uh I I would I would like to move uh I
to pass on Amendment
04808 and I believe everyone should have
a copy at this point
is there a
second second representative Freeman
second's motion do you want to speak to
the amendment yes thank you um I think
that this uh Amendment language uh
clarifies some of the discussion that
came up uh during the hearing um in that
um I
facilitation um uh is uh has different
param
than neutral conference and
mediation uh so in uh Roman
2 uh you'll see the uh paragraphs that
apply only to neutral conference and
mediation uh not I IEP
facilitations uh to clarify the
differentiation uh between um those
three uh dispute resolution uh methods
any comments from the
second no thank you madam
chair any other discussion
representative bbon uh yes I have a
question for uh chairman cordelli
actually two um first is uh who help who
um did you work with in developing this
language um and the second question just
curious why you removed um on page two
um of the amendment uh line 11 and 12
and you actually moved it
to um just on the first page lines 13
and 14 it's about the adoption of rules
is there any particular reason it was
done that way and also like I said um
where did the where who who was
responsible for determining this
language in To better clarify right
there were a number of people who were
here at the um at the hearing who worked
on this uh as well as the um special
edit Advocate um was involved in this as
well and one other question um and and I
assume this is a response to the audit
um that this this language needs to be
clarified correct uh yes this this was
um brought up during the audit as well
the due process special audit of last
year
any other representative
wock thank you madam chair um just a qu
question represent qu I make sure I'm
reading this right um when it talks
about the following sub paragraphs in
plural Glen is that including
B right after in the bottom line 30 is
that not included
B I'm reading as incl including B but I
thought you may have met only a but I
could be wrong my wife tells me that no
I I believe ABC D apply to Roman Roman
two alternative does yes okay thank you
so much thank you m chair any other
discussion just again a clarification of
why that particular sentence was moved
about the rules into 1B rather than
where it was on uh at the end of the
section on page two line 11 and
uh I I believe it was just to um make
clear that the rules would be uh in
relation to all three um methods of
dispute
resolution um
whether that move was required um it
probably was not required but um that's
what they uh developed with the
amendment in their discussions so the
clarification was just to make sure that
the rules appli to all three methods
okay thank
you representative Murray uh thank you
um Madam Vice chair um my question for
the chair as well is are do you envision
that all of the the rules making
Authority granted um would be the same
for neutral conference and mediation as
it would be for IEP since we are they're
technically separate from one another
right I I I believe that the rules would
not apply in Mass to all three but there
would be individual there would be rules
specific to each of the three I see okay
so you you're envisioning that Ru making
would be granted individually to each of
those correct yes I think I do
any other
discussion okay we have an OTP motion on
Amendment
04808 and I recognized
clerk chairman Noble yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative n Nat yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative balbon yes representative
selik yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman
cordelli yes 17 y zero
Nays so we're back to the main bill
would you like to put another Motion in
yes thank you very much much I would
like to move a to pass with Amendment
0480 h0
second representative Mor
second any
discussion nothing
further okay we have a OTP motion on HB
532 and I recognize a
click oh I'm sorry otpa yes thank
you chairman Noble yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative baloni yes representative
Cel yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes and
chairman cordelli yes 17 y zero
Nays consent yes um consent is fine with
everybody
yeah um one additional um bill that we
uh uh discussed um with the uh ranking
member um was House Bill uh
564 if we
could turn to that
bill
yeah oh you want to do it I'll Mo to R
we're going to open the executive
session on HB 564 relative to the
adoption of school administrative unit
budgets and I recognize representative
cordelli for a
motion uh thank you m chairman um I
would like to move uh that we retain
house buillt 564
is there a
second representative moris
seconds discussion from the maker of the
motion thank you um we had this
bill um last term as
well and we moved um I believe it was
either retain or interim study on it um
we uh ended up not doing anything with
that uh but I think that um during the
hearing um that we had um a week ago on
this bill I think there was still
confusion um related uh to um some of
the provisions especially um in relation
to uh single uh District saus versus
multi-district saus and how that would
um apply in each case uh to separating
out the uh SAU budget from The District
budget um I think this since this is the
um Second Time Around in two years with
this budget um I think maybe we could U
take a look at this um uh during the
fall um there's no rush on this um we
just have to would um uh report uh out
on it uh in November and it would be
taken up on the house floor then in
January I believe
um but I think um at least you know
let's take another look since since this
is the uh Second Time Around on it and
see if we can get some uh clarification
and um uh come to agreement on how this
might work in both
instances any discussion from the
second any other
discussion okay
we have a OT I'm sorry our retain motion
on um HB 564 and I recogniz the
clerk chairman Noble yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative Litchfield yes
representative McDonald yes
representative tenar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative B yes representative
celik yes representative
kuger yes representative Snodgrass yes
chairman cordelli yes 17 y zero
Nays thank you that I um it doesn't have
to we don't have to it doesn't go
anywhere okay yeah right this this stays
with the committee so it doesn't go to
the floor or anything so um we are now
good with uh uh 564 you write it on here
correct uh yes right you can write it on
there that it's retained
yeah
right so um let's uh take a look at uh I
think there's two or three more bills
that we want to uh try and address this
morning uh let's take a look next at
House Bill 676
not
onle yeah we might one
more
right yes House Bill
676 is relative to the composition and
responsibility of the parent and
education service provider advisory
commission and establishing education
Freedom account impact and parental
satisfaction
surveys well open the executive session
on HB 676 and I recognize representative
Court Deli for a motion thank you uh I
would like to move ought to pass on
House Bill 67 6 is there a
second I'll second that representative
Freeman seconds discussion
representative cordelli thank you um
this legislation um uh really goes into
two areas um the first uh part of the
bill um Roman um one and excuse me uh
sections one and two on the first page
um relate to the EFA education service
provider advisory commission which is
currently in
statute um last year uh I believe it was
during during an EFA oversite uh
committee meeting um this commission
came under discussion um because it
turned out that well in current statute
um if anyone wants to look at it it it's
F5 Roman 2 um um indicates that um the
meetings of this
commission um are not
mandated they are subject to the call of
the um director of the uh children's
scholarship fund who is the
administrator for the program um and at
that point um they did not um
have any meetings um because it was not
considered um that they were uh uh
needed
um there was also discussion about the
um the makeup of the committee and the
membership
involved um so I I put this bill in U
wanting to
address um those concerns that had come
up during the uh oversight committee
meeting so the first um part of it Roman
2 uh clarifies uh some things about the
membership of the um of the
committee um and uh includes that uh the
number of committee members that would
constitute a quorum because that had not
been in statute
previously um the second part of that en
Roman
three um requires that this commission
be uh uh convened on a quarterly basis
and more often if
necessary
um and that uh the uh commission um had
two UH
responsibilities um and that's in 3A and
B uh first was to uh re uh review any
appeals that education service providers
um who were denied uh admittance or um
were removed from the program um the
this commission would hear appeals of
those service
providers um and two uh to look at the
uh program application
process and also the uh approval process
for account
expenses and the approval of Education
service providers um those three things
um so that was in relation to the uh Pro
service provider advisory
commission the second part um which is
uh starts on uh line 24 on the first
page uh section
three uh adds two surveys that would be
required and these are um identical uh
pretty much
um except entitle uh to surveys that
have been required for the past
decade um or so um with the uh tax
credit scholarship program which was
initiated uh 12 years ago um and much of
that information is available
online um in relation to those
surveys and the first survey um would be
a parental satisfaction
survey um many programs um of choice
around the nation uh do surveys like
this annually in terms of uh parental
satisfaction um and that is on uh Roman
1 on the second
page
um um part of that survey would be um
whether the parent is satisfied with
their new uh
um their new education option and uh
also um if they have seen academic
Improvement um in in their child the
second survey would be uh in relation to
uh uh families who are actually moving
uh out of a public school into uh the
education Freedom account program
um and um basically uh asking um for uh
their reason for uh doing that um and if
they are paying additional expenses over
and above the education Freedom account
for their new service um Education
Service
options um so those are the
uh two surveys and the uh
to the
commission that um that are in this
bill any comment from the
second yes thank you madam chair
um I I think this bill addresses a lot
of um issues and questions people have
had about the EFA accounts and um given
the popularity of the program I think
that any information that may assist
strengthening Public Schools um would be
met with an immense amount of
enthusiasm um this survey is not to
point fingers at anyone but to find out
where the gaps or the holes may be and
um you know provide that information
along the line so the public schools may
want to address what what they've seen
on this and and um and an extra layer of
protection around programs that receive
EFA money that may not live up to the
standard that we all need so I I I'm
strongly in favor of this bill and I
hope that all of my colleagues will
support us in this thank
you any other discussion representative
Hall thank you madam chair um I
personally be voting no on this the
survey when it says that the it's an
impact survey I don't think it's going
to have any impact I could all your
people all you people that have efas
right now are going to answer yes and I
don't think I could give you the result
before anyone even takes the survey um
so think the questions are
um they're not going to give us what we
want and if it's an I don't think it's
going to show us gaps holes um and I
don't think it's going to do
anything thank you representative
balbon thank you um first of all um this
committee that's going to conduct uh the
survey uh these members are handpicked
by the director of the scholarship Pro
program and the only represent four
counties so there's no real oversight in
this committee per se because there's no
diverse membership which another U
committee that might be really looking
at the impact would you would include
maybe legislators members of the public
Educators as well as um people involved
in the EFA program um and uh to uh
representative Hall's point it only
measures parental satisfaction and the
lead and these questions are very
leading and subjective and it provides
no objective actual achievement data on
the students so I don't think this is
going to give you any good information
at
all represent wock thank you mam chair R
Cordell just a clarification I may um on
the fir I'm on line uh nine and 10 of
page
two and I'm looking at the the uh first
question if I understand what you'd said
that this is supposed to be the
education Freedom account parent
certification I mean satisfaction uh I'm
looking at uh line a and it talks about
the education tax credit
program uh yes that um is uh an error
that was supposed to be
changed um from the as I said this was
taken out of the tax credit scholarship
program and that was to have been
changed okay but as it is I'm sorry
right as it is it isn't okay may may I
follow CH sure thank you um just a
follow other it's a question another
clarification question but it will
follow is there any more questions in
the survey Beyond these
three
um the um uh as indicated in nine it
shall include these but I think it
doesn't restrict it to just those three
questions this is may may I so do we
know what the other ones are um
the uh uh this survey uh could well be
uh
expanded um um Beyond those three
questions and um I'm trying to remember
if the tax credit scholarship program
questions are expanded or not and but I
I cannot remember that for sure finally
matter chair I made just a concluding
comment I would agree with
representative Hall and Bon this is this
makes Rosal look happy this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy you get the
answers before you send the survey out
there's no chance I have right answer
thank you representative Murray um thank
you Madame Vice chair um one point of
concern that I also have in addition to
the my other colleagues um is with with
regard to the fact that um sections one
and two um seem to indicate that maybe
the parent isn't being asked questions a
b and c and then it's broken out and it
says the survey shall include the
following question to the parent or
legal guardian so I'm I'm also concerned
and Confused it seems like all of these
questions would go to the entity who uh
holds or has some agency over the my
class wallet program so I'm confused as
to why uh in addition to the leading
questions that I think what why it is
broken out the way it
is Pur cordelli thank you uh yes uh uh
section one in relation to the advisory
commission is totally separate from the
survey um the surveys would not be aimed
at um members of the uh advisory
commission I guess repr m uh with all
due respect I
I so the top three questions wouldn't be
too it seems like the top three
questions a b and c would be to a parent
and then question two the survey itself
should include the following question to
the parent or legal guardian as
well so
I are there two different sets of
surveys within I I guess that's what I'm
trying to understand right um I believe
in the tax credit uh scholarship program
um they are independent surveys I see
but and and and you said this was a an
scrier error with regard to the
education tax credit program that was
supposed to say something else right ah
okay right yes um it it wasn't changed
um in the draft um but I would uh uh
submit a floor amendment to make that uh
uh
correction any other oh representative
Freeman thank you madam chair um
I I I heard I heard um I Heard a comment
about how um all of the questions were
missleading and they really wouldn't
address anything that the parents wanted
to do and I wanted to point out on page
one starting at line 26 the education
Freedom account impact survey shall be
do a document developed by the
Department of Education and given to the
parents whose students who have exited a
public school Under the Pres provisions
of this chapter there survey shall
solicit the reasons for seeking the
education Freedom account and any
suggested improvements desired in the
public school day or leaving so I do
believe that this bill passed with that
excuse me with that survey would be a
mechanism for public schools to see if
there's any holes or gaps that they may
able to be able to fix thank
you
represent if I may respond to the uh
represent pres from winr
uh identifying what she has spoke
about there's only 15% of the people
that ever left Public School 85% of the
people who are involved in this account
never attended a public school so how
you going to find all that small 15%
left in in representative
information I'm sorry and and thank you
and the ones have have already come back
um it's a small number but I the ones
that 85% never went there so this is a
really small survey for a really limited
piece of the answers you're going to
receive thank you madam chair may
I thank you and thank you representative
for the comment and while I agree 15% is
while I agree 15% is not a huge number
any information is good
information represent Murray thank you
madam Vice chair uh just to the the the
members point about misleading I just
want to make sure that we're on the same
page there was no assertation that it
was misleading we were saying the
questions were leading which I think is
a different set of circumstances leading
questions mean that they would arrive at
the same answer an expected answer not a
Mis we weren't there was no comment to
say that we were misleading
anything just one one other question I
just said and if you truly wanted to get
a survey I I would I would also include
um
questions given to the parents of
students who took the were in the EA
program and then left and went back to
public school that might give you some
other very pertinent
information any other
discussion representative dve thank you
uh Madam chairman I I don't think we're
Limited in what questions we can ask and
I don't think they need to be stipulated
by Statute which are in there but those
that was good suggestion
that representative
cig thank you um I just have in my notes
that there was going to be an amendment
pass so I'd been expect or brought
forward so I was questioning based on
clarifying accountability and other
things but if the chairman is going to
be bringing a floor amendment to address
what our technical errors perhaps it
might also expand the scope of the
survey in some way to include those who
are never going to attend um Public
School R under any circumstance
anyway any other
discussion representative H thank you
madam chair I have a question just for
anyone so why does a survey have to be
in law to conduct a
survey okay um it uh does not um I had
actually talked to the skill children's
scholarship fund um about doing a
parental Sur uh satisfaction survey um
but um they had uh not as of the time
that I filed this so I wanted to uh uh
make sure that it got done and it um
wasn't left a
voluntary um uh Choice um I wanted to
move it forward and make sure that it
happened uh so I included that in the
legislation um because I was already
going to submit the legislation about
the advis
committee thank
you representative Woodcock last one um
I'd like to follow up on repres comment
I think it was and I want to go back to
my my fellow representative there from
the South Shore I think what is really
important is if we're if we're really
trying to find information I think she
has an excellent point which is let's
survey all of the people in the EFA I
would really like to know why the 85% of
those folks that took the EFA never
attended public school if we're really
trying to figure out what's wrong with
public school and we have 85% of these
people never stepped in the door I like
to find out why that would give us
things some credibility information if
it's just because they have they want to
go a higher Academic Place and they have
that's fine but there must be other
reasons for people who aren't in that
same category that's what I like to know
if we really intent on trying to use
this to improve public education for the
K12 we have there let's include everyone
I I I can support that I can't support
this piece thank you representative
McDonald thank you madam chair in
response to the previous comment I
Believe by representative Hall we do
have other surveys and law to put a
survey and law is in a novel concept
such as the euph foris behavior survey
ybs that we talk about quite
frequently
question representative Murray thank you
madam Vice chair um the other the other
portion of this that I'm wondering about
is there is no opportunity with regard
to sort of missing set of demographics
that we were just talking about with
representative celik um I don't see
there being any opportunity for anything
other than like a few sort of
prescripted agree strongly disagree
there's no sort of um like short answer
area that I it seems to be again like a
very limited way to be able to respond
to the
questions any other
discussion representative hul thank you
thank you uh if I could comment in
reference to the survey the survey
itself is not in law right reference to
the survey the youth risk behavior
survey just reference to it but the
actual survey is not into the law
correct
question and my understanding of the
bill in front of us is this survey is
not in law it says other questions could
be added and those questions aren't in
law either similar to that
survey any other discussion
see none we have a o OTP motion on HB
676 and I recognize a
clerk thank you madam
chair chairman Noble yes representative
dry yes representative Freeman yes
representative litfield yes
representative mcdonnald yes
representative tzar yes representative
moris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell no representative
Murray no representative Woodcock
absolutely not representative Hall no
representative bon no Representative
selig no Representative kuger no repr
Snodgrass no and chairman cordelli yes
nine Ys eight Nays
chairman cordelli could I request I I've
just been called to testify next door
would it be possible for us to take two
minutes for me to go give my tesy
quickly
um while representative C's gone maybe
we can all take a look and read um the
side by side that we just got uh for
house bill um 440 and 362 did everyone
get copies of those so we have a little
bit of time to take a look at
that guess I don't need this clerk thing
I can keep that pass that
down hang on look I have an abundance of
paper here yeah representative Woodcock
Northshore I'm not from the Southshore
oh
we'll just take a brief break while the
representatives T toine and then come
back to executive
session
e
e e
I think we're
all all back uh no not
quite here he
is okay
um we have a side by side um comparing
House Bill
440 with a
362 um which we talked about uh taking
up this morning um there looks to
be a slight difference in uh
362 which adds um a uh departmental
waiver um to the language which is not
in 440 uh 440 we did pass the other
day
um and correct me if I'm wrong um when
we're talking about 440 did someone um
say and I don't
have
um my note but um um Mr beay from the
Department Department of Education from
the
um
uh um from the Department um had
supported uh House Bill 440 he preferred
he said
440 aligned with the rules that's
yeah yeah that's okay I contacted Jeff
beard The Who heads theard I'm sorry yes
just bearded from um CTE and he said
that 440 align with the rules and so he
just didn't I don't think he preferred
but he just said that would aligned best
with the
rules um yeah represent of Paul yeah
just so this side by side actually
yesterday we amended it to have initial
added that word initial to this on the
left hand side 440 just letting you know
that the word initial is there
oh right
yes
right F the comments um I'll just
mention that um uh I did uh I had been
in contact with uh um Mr applebe from
the Department in relation to
362 and uh he was comfortable with the
language in 362
um so um I have messaged him that U
maybe he can talk with Mr
beard and um come to an agreement as to
um whether the uh departmental waiver um
require mentioned in
362 um should be part of um whatever we
pass um so maybe we can um hold off um
on 362 until we get departmental
agreement on um on the
language represent Marie I have question
sure well no might as well go ahead um
so one question that I did have was
there were two small sections on 362
which talk about the Schoolboard
submitting a waiver and then the
department then having the authority to
submit a waiver and I wondered which
entity was reached could respond first
or could that be put
in could the local school board deny a
waiver and then the department accept a
waiver and then vice versa could it put
be put in conflict with one another
accidentally by any chance okay will
yeah this how we going to take no action
and maybe I'm interpreting it incorrect
it just seems like there's two different
ways that a waiver can be brought
forward I guess is what I was trying to
say
right um okay why don't we um hold off
on this then
um forther comment yeah thanks clearly
um CL if we go with the 362 piece so
then is initial going to be put in there
we talked about the word initial uh
yesterday for 440 if we if we go with
overlaying overlapping 362 could we be
sure the initial is in
there
um right uh you on the first line
see be an
initial
an okay is the question you may know
this because I don't if I may follow
up right can't
can't the department already do
that for any any allw waiver for they
want
um allowing for waivers I thought that
the commissioner could um probably um in
rules but if it's in rules it should
have a statutory
reference um so we uh if they can we
don't need the end part that's all right
yeah yeah we'll we'll um raise that with
the Department okay thank you yeah just
a procedural question um if we if we
already passed the first one right what
would happen next if we chose this one
if we decide this one was better it's
the uh if they're uh
conflicting um I know when it applies to
statutes if they are conflicting
statutes um it's the one that passed
last
that that uh is referred to
right so I I um I'm not I would assume
that the same would hold to uh uh to
bills re um Jen do you have
any
right that's true right
right this the speaker could just put in
when he got on the floor he could just
kill one on the
floor um right or
um right we we could um if some of the
language of
362 um is um
preferred to 440 what we could also do
is um we've already passed 440 um we
could um uh go to the Senate and ask
them to uh amend the bill in the amend
House Bill 440 in the Senate uh to
include requested language from the
Department that would be another option
would could could it be an OP I'm
sorry go
no oh
okay right okay right that we just we
just did that was it yesterday okay
yes right could you repr repeat what you
said so um 440 hasn't been sent over um
okay right so it it's still our bill so
we can do whatever we want with 440
still
Yes represent Murray and then
additionally if both were to somehow
leave this committee and enter the floor
there was always a possibility that one
or the other could come back to this
committee correct and be sent back to
the committee we referred essentially
yes or you can kill one on the floor yes
right yeah we we have we have a bunch of
options
yes represent s thank you Mr chair just
procedurally in my previous committee we
had uh and representative tzar may
remember this we had a similar situation
where we had a few different bills that
were fairly similar in our first year
which we we retained a couple of them so
that should one have difficulty making
it through the full process we had it to
amend and adapt so that we could submit
it during the second year so I just
wanted to offer that that was also a
possibility that's a good point yes
we've done that in education in uh a
number of instances yes I I think the
CTE centers are anxious for something
like this to happen because they're
having a hard
time oh okay okay they're looking
forward to this yeah um so uh um we will
hold on to um maybe 440 in our position
if we can possession um until we clar
ification from the
Department
yep
right representative Mor representative
Morse thank you uh so similar to what
you mentioned about kind of retaining it
in case one fails the other one can kind
of pass my other question would be about
kind of consolidating them together and
doing like a Flor amendment that has
everything combined right or or since we
have 440
still in our possession we can just
amend
440 or um after a reconsideration of
that right so yeah we would only need
one one of them so yeah as soon as I get
clarification from the Department uh we
can move forward in one of these
directions follow up yes so I guess that
begs a question of combining them and
then holding the other one as a retain
just in
case we we can do that yes
not yet let's wait and see what the
department has to say um you know they
could say you know just go with 440 and
it's okay and then you know we'll be
we'll be
set
um
okay um so we'll hold on that until we
get
clarification um I wanted to bring up
one additional
bill um
today which is uh House Bill 384 on uh
bullying um we had a work
session um yesterday on the three uh
bullying
bills
um and um this is an early Bill
384 um I I think that there were um
comments during the work
session
with several um concerns people had um
with this um bill in relation to the
referrals um to for
chins um also the required uh conflict
resolution um Provisions in it was
um uh was felt not be appropriate maybe
in some cases especially in um uh
Elementary
grades um I I think that um as we move
forward with the two non early bullying
bills um if there are ideas from this um
they could be incorporated into whatever
bullying Bill we move forward
with um so um my recommendation is that
um we
uh
um uh do not move forward with 384 and I
would be willing to make a motion um but
uh I'd like to hear some discussion
before any mo motion is put forward on
this
bill rent Cornell Thank you Mr chair um
and I agree with what you said I I think
the the chin petition and the conflict
resolution and also the bullying officer
was a big question um of who that was
going to be what training they were
going to have how that was going to help
um so I I just there were good parts to
it but I think on the whole I I would
agree with you that that this at this
bill parts of it could be incorporated
into the other two that I think we're
trying to combine
represent Morris I can agree with that
as well also it kind of this bill goes
above its own authority on lines 15
through 25 requiring parental classes
for the parents of those accused and I
think that's kind of government
overreach and we can't really mandate
things like that thank you any
further discussion before we actually uh
entertain a motion
see none um do you want to take the G
make the motion okay great um
right um okay I recognize um uh Vice
chairman Noble for a motion on House
Bill 384 prohibiting bullying in schools
I move
itl thank you is there a second I'll
second D repr
moris um
would the the maker of the motion like
to discuss her itl motion I think
everybody else already discussed it so
we are
good R Morris no good any further
comments from the
committee everyone wants in few minutes
extra for lunch I guess um so uh the
motion is itl and see no further uh
discussion uh I uh call on the clerk
when she is ready I chairman Noble yes
representative dry yes representative
Freeman yes representative Lichfield yes
representative McDonnell yes
representative tenar yes representative
Morris yes representative NATO yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Murray yes representative
Woodcock yes representative Hall yes
representative Bon yes representative
cig yes representative kuger yes
representative Snodgrass yes chairman
cordelli yes 17 y zero nay is consent
okay with
everybody great um I think that that
wraps up the bills that we wanted to um
exec today um and uh since we are
getting through our executive sessions
in in um good order um I will keep that
a mind in mind when scheduling future
exec sessions uh in March um so thank
you very much um anything else before we
break for
lunch
pardon
390 no we did not
great thank you everybody and we're back
at 1 for uh several hearings this
afternoon
e
for
e e
welcome um do we have any um people
wishing to testify on
653 um maybe we can get
um yeah
thank you very much um we have three
bills four bills um for this afternoon
um and I just wanted to mention um one
other thing um I got uh an email um
based on um hearing yesterday um from uh
for deca
Rebecca fet at the
department
um uh in relation to uh comments about
um uh Behavior discipline
problems um while I have no data to
support or contract contradict this
information I would say from my
experience for some of our children yes
they do have some of the more difficult
behaviors that can result in
disciplinary removals speaking of kids
with
disabilities many times these behaviors
are due to their disabilities and
working with them to
disminucion of the afternoon which is
House Bill
653 establishing a pilot program within
the Department of Education to implement
alternatives to restraint and seclusion
of students and uh we
welcome uh the prime sponsor
representative
patrio well thank you Mr chairman and
thank you members of the committee for
the record I'm representative Peter
patrino from the town of Milford and the
legislation before you originated as a
result of an inm study which I chaired
this past summer in response to House
Bill 1269 which came before the children
and family law committee last year and
that bill called for visual and auditory
recordings in each uh use of restraint
and seclusion if included in the
students IEP now a number of parents
testified in support of the bill some
sharing disturbing photos of their
children with bruis marks and injuries
and alleging abuse and neglect on the
part of the school staff now since
students with IEPs are mainstreamed the
committee felt that the bill would
require security cameras in every
classroom throughout the state and even
at one point during the inm study it was
suggested that teachers wear body
cameras like like the
police so the majority felt that these
measures were impractical and to say the
least extremely costly but the testimony
given by the parents was
heartfelt and I personally believe that
it would be very inappropriate for us to
Simply itl the bill without giving any
due concern for the parents uh who
testified so what we did was we formed
an interim study and what we discovered
was that there are alternative methods
that appear promising in reducing the
need for restraint and seclusion uh we
looked into the approach developed by Dr
Ross Green the director of lies and the
balance we heard testimony from Toby
Iselin who's the co-director of the wio
school in Hillsboro who reported
positive results uh from their
alternative approaches and we also
examined the reforms made by the state
of Maine in this regard which has
acknowledged that current methods are
not effective in altering students
behavior but instead can be traumatizing
and cause lasting negative effects now
Maine acknowledges that restraint and
seclusion should only be used in
emergency situations when a child's
Behavior creates an UNS safe condition
but that alternative methods need to be
employed to reduce such instances so if
you look at the Maine Department of
education's website they say we do know
that there are best practice proactive
Crisis Prevention methodologies that can
be
implemented so the result of our work is
this legislation which we are calling
the safe schools pilot project within
the Department of Education um it's
purpose is exploratory not for us to
implement any one program but to Pilot
approved trauma-based informed practices
in schools uh which wish to participate
uh the full details of inflation are
given within the bill so lastly I would
just like to thank Senator MCU for
filing uh his initial bill last year uh
he had good intentions and I would also
like to thank the office of the child
advocate for their assistance in helping
us throughout the interim study and for
helping us draft this legislation thank
you Mr chairman happy to take any
questions thank you uh represent
Murray thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative patuna for taking my
question one uh within the definition of
the word seclusion I understand when
we're talking about um alternatives to
restraint would seclusion um be purely
defined in a a disciplinary setting or
if a child for example is over
stimulated and need to um self- relocate
or do something else would that qualify
as seclusion seclusion means exactly
what it means it is removing the child
from uh the situation and putting them
in some type of isolation and on a
personal note I can tell you that I
experienced it when I was in
kindergarten all right when I was doing
something that my teachers felt were
just inappropriate and to be honest with
you I thought I was a pretty good kid
all right and there were times when they
would put me in the closet and close CL
the door and I was wondering like why
but apparently whatever I was doing
wasn't pleasing to them so yeah
seclusion means literally removing
somebody and putting them in
isolation I gu follow follow yes my
question is whether or not if if this
definition I understand what you're
saying with regard to a punitive sort of
removal I'm talking about if a child is
removing themselves out of an
environment where they're over
stimulated would that be considered I
see self if it's
self-imposed if it's self-imposed you're
asking I don't believe so thank
you
further questions of the
sponsor um I just have one
um um on um Roman
1B um it talks about the purposes of the
pilot um so the
programs um that are to be used
in the um restraint and seclusion
pilot um are defined in lines 9 through
11 is is that
correct um where it talks about U
evidence-based uh programs provided by a
national Clearing House and it gave um
an example so programs from um that
clearing house um are to be used by
these pilot schools for the pilot study
that is correct okay thank you rent
salik thank you so much and thank you
for taking my my question um and again
congratulations on having one of your
former students give you a shout out
last week during testimony but thank you
in um on page one line 15 and 16 um it
says evidence-based alternatives to
restraint and cusion shall not include
programs that use restraint for
seclusion that makes sense but Crisis
Prevention training which I sort of
understand but deescalation training or
behav management training I'm curious
why we wouldn't use something that
involves deescalation training right um
and so I'm I'm just trying to get
clarification on that portion of the
bill exactly what we're looking at are
alternatives to what is currently being
used because we're acknowledging that
current practices aren't working and so
we do want to look at
Alternatives and and that is why you
have a study program to basically look
to implement ways other than what we are
currently using so we are currently
using uh deescalation but we're
acknowledging that U it's not always
working so we're looking for other ways
to make things
better represent thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative for bringing
this forward I'm looking at page one
line
24 and it mentions two schools with the
highest per capita incidents of
restraints and inclusion is that a
highest group of per capita or I guess
my question is how could there be two
schools that are the highest wouldn't
there only be one school that's the
definitive highest okay I hear what
you're saying but I mean I think the
intent is to look at schools that have
the highest percentage of these
incidences uh reped and to have at least
two of them okay thank you that's
correct represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
I'm just curious
um I'm I'm curious about the piece
around this being
um an alternative to restraint and
seclusion and not being able to use
it alongside Crisis Prevention
deescalation or behavior
management um I think and maybe you can
answer this for me is there any reason
why you wouldn't want to use this as
well as those other modalities in order
to address a reduction in um restraints
yes and again um current methods that we
are using don't seem to be effective I
hear exactly what you're saying but what
we're looking at is to look at
alternatives to what currently is being
used used and we can f we can look to
the state of Maine that has basically
outlawed uh restraint and seclusion and
has acknowledge that it should only be
used in instances when uh there's issues
of safety that are concerned and so
Maine is looking at these alternative
methods which is what we would like to
explore we want to see if they are being
successful and if we can Implement a
pilot program and see if it's something
that we in New Hampshire should
incorporate so basically to have
everything at our disposal to reduce
those situations when we heard testimony
from those parents and we saw
photographs of children who were bruised
and injured like I said we got to find a
better way so as we're looking for A
Better Way We Came Upon Alternatives
that seem to be working but we don't
know for sure if they are working until
we have a pilot program and test them
out we can look to Maine and take a look
at some of the data there it is
promising can I have a followup Mr yes
you may thank you and thank you for that
um I I I will tell I will tell you what
my concern with this is and then I will
ask you a question um my now adult son
is on the Spectrum and when he was in
the second grade he had a lot of
behavior issues and he was a big kid and
physically he would lash out
occasionally now if we hadn't used any
of these
techniques that are currently available
I don't think we would have been able to
address
his
meltdowns and with deescalation so my
concern would be taking these programs
out strictly for one program um and I I
I do hear what you're saying about a p
pilot program do you have any numbers
from Maine any percentages any cases
that would make me feel more comfortable
about implementing Justice and no other
of these modalities sure well the state
of Maine on the department of ucation
website details what they're doing there
uh so that's one place that you can look
as far as data I don't know uh
specifically uh what they are reporting
in that regard uh but I do hear what
you're saying um my wife who was a first
grade teacher for many years is 5 foot
tall and she has told me some of her
first graders were as tall if not bigger
than her okay and so I've heard this
same situation at home um but again um
those types of modalities uh need to be
used in situations where things escalate
to the point where they become dangerous
so they're not being excluded uh even in
the state of Maine they acknowledge that
yes there are times when these methods
need to be used but we want to minimize
it and look for something different that
maybe can prevent it from happening in
the first place thank you represent
Morris uh thank you Mr chair I just had
a question as to what some of these
Alternatives might look like well again
that's a very good question and I and
and I believe that uh there are a few
that I um alluded to in my presentation
and um you can again uh look at the
department of education's website in
Maine and you can spell it all out in
detail s thank you so much this is just
a technical question about the
composition of the bill itself on page
two um I see Roman 3 a b c e but not D
and I'm just wondering if I'm missing D
somewhere or if it's been misplaced
somewhere and I'm just trying to mix
Roman numeral 2 a b c 1 2 3 4 5 C then
down to D then we begin ran numeral
three I don't where do you see D I don't
have D on mine and it's right it jumps
to line e on line 23 on page two but I
have C and then I have E I don't have d
right I think are are we missing is it
me or are we missing
D could be um yeah probably a typo and
alls okay I just I just want to make
sure I hadn't yeah no you didn't didn't
miss anything
okay okay thank you or unless we both
did you should be any further uh
comments thank you very much I
appreciate it yeah thank you very much
thank you Mr chairman one more question
okay thank you uh Mr chair um it did say
that we were still awaiting a fiscal
note did you have an updated fiscal note
or is that in the file somewhere
that half
million okay somehow my my copy didn't
have the pistal note on
that
okay thank you
right there there is
um a fiscal
note um that was revised on January 24th
looks
like um Senator MCU
welcome to the education policy
committee Senator thank Mr chairman nice
to see you
all this bill is this topic has come
back to a different committee so I'll
just give a little bit of background I
don't have a lot of prepared testimony
and I just indicated one minute but I
might take a little bit longer given
some of the questions that came up my
name is Senator Tim mugh I represent
District 11 which are the towns of marac
Milford hemmer and Wilton and this bill
came from from a group of constituents
in marac that brought brought the
legislators together and told us
shockingly that hundreds if not
thousands of students are
restrained in our schools using padded
rooms and other means every year every
reporting period and this was a foreign
topic to me couldn't imagine a school
with a padded room I imagine many of you
are my age are similar
also might have been a little bit
shocked to know that almost every school
has a restraint room restraint or
seclusion
room um it was pretty pretty shocking
actually to hear the numbers 1,400 1500
in the in the reporting period and some
of the schools were uh hundreds a year
and then we dived into the details to
understand why and what types of
students and what types of incidents
were involved and the original request
was to uh audio and video record these
practices so we could better understand
why and safety and and as you could
imagine that um Unleashed a whole
Pandora's box of discussion you know
privacy concerns for teachers and
students and all kinds of things uh and
that led to the bill being heavily
discussed over the summer uh in uh I
think it was retained and re-referred
and some great work done by the sponsors
who uh
graciously brought it back uh this this
time uh this session uh in in this form
so I guess the bottom line for me is
there are too many students being
restrained
forcefully um in general so whatever we
can do and whatever this committee can
do and I'll help when it makes it to the
other body whatever we can do to reduce
that number is a good thing and I don't
know that this particular language is
exact ly correct we've had some great
questions thank you for those already um
about you know what exactly what is the
evidence that we're basing these
practices on what are the current
practices uh you know what will the
pilot mean uh you know what are the two
highest I think it means you know the
top two on the list right and I can
probably tell you and there's some folks
behind me who will give you the exact
numbers I have some in my head but I'm
sure they've changed the numbers have
been updated annually so of the list of
the the 10 schools with the most
incident of documented restraint and
seclusion um will'll take the top two I
think that's the intent right you know
the top two on that list that's what
they mean by the two highest um you know
what are some of the alternate means and
why would we uh in in line 15 am I just
need my glasses here in line 15 uh you
know why would we want to
exclude um
methods that we're already doing well
why would we fund a uh pilot to do the
same things and also but I'll get to the
funding in a second um why would we want
why would we want to try something that
we're already doing so this pilot
doesn't intend to examine those same
practices where we already have some
data so we want to try some new things
things like positive behavioral support
timeouts teaching replacement skills
those are some of the things where there
are evidence from other states and other
teaching and I don't
necessarily um think that the California
based evidence Clearing House for child
welfare is
necessarily where we want to look it
just happens to be one that's being
current currently used and there's a
body of work on it um
so the the pilot and the legislature
should look at all all all Alternatives
um and perhaps this committee may choose
either in subcommittee or a committee of
the whole uh to revise or clean up that
language and make it either um either
more specific or perhaps a little more
broad uh to give the educational
institutions a bit a bit of Freedom uh
to use a variety of evidence-based
programs so for me as a clinical
researcher uh you know peer-reviewed
published data in uh high level journals
is is the standard that I tend to tend
to apply I mean randomized Control Data
randomized control trials are great I'm
not sure that applies in the educational
world so anyhow so that's where I am uh
fewer incidents of restraint fewer
incidents of seclusion are better uh in
my opinion um deescalation is always
good I think our our teachers are are
trained to do that um happy to answer
questions and there are experts behind
me that can answer I think in detail on
the specific practice itself I know
there are some experts on the committee
on that um but I'm happy to answer
questions hopefully that a little bit of
color on how we got to this point and
why this bill is back in a different
very different
form um thank you very much uh questions
for the senator r s thank you so much
and thank you for taking my question you
you made reference at the beginning of
your testimony you might have comments
about the fiscal note and I just
wondered if you might follow up on that
I did and I didn't thank
you um I I did notice there was no
appropriation attached which I suppose
is convenient in a budget year um and uh
and and I don't think we know exactly
what it'll cost um if I suppose there'll
be some cost I'm not sure I agree with
the indeterminate cost or the need to
hire a new person to administer this
program um I it's I think it's naturally
the tendency of the department to say
yes we need another body and see what
happens um I can tell you well in my in
this senator's opinion it's highly
unlikely that they would get one
um who can say really until we get to
the passage of the the trailer bill of
House Bill 2 and that's a long way from
today um so I do I think it will need
some funding yes do I think it's worth
it absolutely yeah I I I do where it's
going to
land you the house will have to let the
Senate know and then we'll go from there
I think we're a long way from there but
for me and from what I've heard from the
constituents that requested this a
couple years ago uh it seems to be a
worthwhile expenditure in some fashion
and I don't think a I think a pilot I
mean it's kind of akin to a sunset right
it's one of the tools we use in our
legislative toolbox to find a way find a
way to yes find a way to fixing the
problem
um that's
that's how I look at
it thank you representative Morris thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so line 15 where it says shall
not include programs that use restrain
or seclusion would you still support the
bill if it was changed from shall not to
maybe in a last resort scenario so that
way the pilot program can still be a
trial and error period but they can
still revert as a worst case scenario in
extreme circumstances well sure um I I
think the point of that is is let's look
for different for programs that do
things differently than what we
currently do so sure I'd still support
it um the point is doing the same thing
that we already do is going to produce
the same result so you know why bother
like why why go to the effort of a pilot
program that uses programs that are
doing what we already do we're not going
to get any new data so I think that's I
think that's the intent of that and
maybe it's inelegantly worded but I
think that's the point you know the
definition of insanity is repeating the
same thing over and over and just
expecting a different result so we just
don't want to repeat the same thing that
we're already doing so we're looking for
programs that do something different
such as and the answer to the what's the
something different um are things like
you know positive behavioral support
timeouts teaching replacement skills
those are some of the things that are
commonly found in those other programs
and I'm not saying we don't already do
some of those things because in in
certain cases we do
at least I've I've been you know told we
do
so okay further questions represent
Cornell Thank you thank you for taking
my question line 10 when it's talking
about programs it does say such as the
California evidence-based clearance so
it doesn't have to be through them it's
just that's an example correct yes
correct you're correct in that they
could look someplace else AB absolutely
thank you rury thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um with
regard and maybe this is not a question
for you but with regard to the technical
advisory that the Department of
Education did put out um in uh 2023 I
think September um it does mention um
restraint and seclusion being um
referenced in 126 U to traditional
Public public charter schools publics
and approved non-public schools this
piece of legislations if I'm
interpreting it correctly is only
looking at certain School populations or
is it open to all of those the same um
that the list that I just read so yeah
I'm pretty familiar with the ta uh and I
think this looks wouldn't apply to I
think this applies to all all schools
but I'll I'll leave it to some of the
experts behind me to clarify but the you
know the TA is is what it is it was from
from the
doe yeah no no I appreciate the followup
if I may I I guess I was just looking at
the the cohort of individuals that you
were saying in elementary school a
there's a list of of
types of schools that shall be included
in the pilot program I just wanted to
make sure it could be any of those types
of schools settings I don't see why not
wherever you know wherever these come
from like the two highest per
capita uh schools with these density
populations I I don't think it should be
limited to any
particular School District thank you in
my opinion okay thank you further
questions just keeping the keeping the
goal in mind of reduction of this this
procedure right right yes thank you very
much for your testimony and for being
here thank you Mr chairman thank you so
much
members um Moren and I'm sorry I can't
read the last name Tracy
okay now I can see
it can you hear me yes okay um so I was
the one that um gathered families
together in marac um in regards to uh
the original bill with cameras um
because I I'm a former educator I've
taught preschool all the way up to um
highered and I also am a mom of a
daughter who has prayer Willy syndrome
it's kind of as like autism plus food
type of a thing and at 13 days old they
told me that I better learn Behavior cuz
someday she would be bigger than me so I
have taken every Behavior course there
is Under the Sun um
so I have worked my working with kids
with emotional Behavior disabilities has
been what I have done in the past and I
have only had to restrain one child and
that was we were on a field trip and I
thought he was non-verbal and I thought
he was going to touch a um pizza oven
hot stove on the end and so I grabbed
them and I and I held him them back and
it turns out it wasn't even hot on that
side and that was it and I I worked in
Manchester school districts I worked
with with um students
6'8 with emotional Behavior disabilities
and I had SRO officers ask me to help
deescalate them um this was a life skill
that I needed right but yet I was able
to learn how to do that most kids who
are restrained are between the ages of 4
and 10 maybe 12 um most of them if not
all have disabilities whether they're
documented or not um the families that
came to me and this is why I asked for
the cameras most of them were
non-verbal children who were coming home
with bruises and nobody knew why split
lips um bumps on the heads there's
pictures and that's very scary for a
parent um as far as my professional life
I was blessed to work for UNH at the
institute on disability um back in 2006
to about 2014 doing this exact work of
PBIS in schools I've worked in schools
all over the state um I was actually
even hired as the first um PBIS director
over in lonia where at one of their
elementary schools when I got got there
there was over 3,000 referrals to the
office that's Elementary School by the
time I left it was down to 500 and this
is all about being
proactive um not reactive um what
happens is our brains go into fight or
flight any of us could have a behavior
if we were walking down the street and
somebody started to come after us and we
were feeling threatened our body would
naturally take over and that's what
happens to a lot of these kids so it's
very very important to get there in
deescalate I will say one thing that I
learned which is life space Crisis
Intervention um that was a very amazing
tool that helped keep kids down um
reduce kids um behaviors um typically a
behavior will last for 20 minutes once
that automatic process happens and
unfortunately sometimes us adults end up
escalating it because we talk too much
we get too many people around and stuff
like that um um I did get a call last
week from a a mom in a town close by
that her 7-year-old was out at recess
wouldn't come in from Recess he has
autism came down the slide principal
yelled at him he threw snow he was
thrown into the green room um and so
this is still happening I was shocked
that it it had ever happened I didn't
know that it happened until my daughter
went to an out of placement then I found
out later on that yes Al a lot of
schools here in New Hampshire do have
them um I really think it's about being
proactive it's called ABC data um
blending programs together like Maine
has Maine also has the collaborative
solving problem um process which really
works as well we have PBIS at the state
now um one of the hardest things I think
is doing it with Fidelity and if we're
not doing it with Fidelity and we're not
providing coaching and positive
reinforcement to our leaders our
teachers our
administrators um that it it's just not
going to work but I I really am very
thankful for representative patrino for
bringing this um continuing this moving
forward I would eventually like to see
cameras in these rooms where kids are
not in every classroom um but we're kids
who are nonverbal because let's admit if
you think you might get fired because
you did something wrong and there's a
kidle there that's
nonverbal what are you going to say and
unfortunately a lot of times people well
I know this so I have a daughter who
came to substitute in the school with me
when she was in between her breaks and
college they put her with the hardest
student with no training she has a
sister so she's had Hands-On training
and she's excellent at it but if she
hadn't it would have ended really bad so
so um I guess I I'm very supportive of
anything that will help to reduce
restraints and seclusion in schools
especially if it's happening over and
over again to a child thank you thank
you very much uh
questions represent Cornell Thank you
thank you for taking my question what is
lifespace Crisis Intervention life
spaced Crisis Intervention is a
deescalation tool kind of like CPI um
which CPI is a dis dis deescalation tool
but CPI does talk about restraints this
does not and it has actually four
different methods on using it it's being
able to identify way down here because
you can and um way down here before it
gets to way up here because once you've
gone past that honestly biological
process you have to let it run its
course uh if I could ask um
this bill
prescribes um certain um programs that
are evidence-based by a national
Clearing House and gave an
example um but shall not
include uh programs using Crisis
Prevention training or deescalation
training or behavior management training
based on your experience do you have
thoughts on um those two sections of
this
bill uh could you could you just repat
put that last part again the the last um
part is um evidence-based Alternatives
shall not include for the pilot program
um Crisis Prevention training
deescalation training or behavior
management
training I think actually yeah because
what you could do is look at data and
being ABC data which is not included in
that and putting in plans in place I
think if if it's it's all about being
proactive um if you know and that's why
it's so important to collect the right
data you can even if a child is
non-verbal you can everybody starts to
have um um routines that we just it
keeps us safe when we do the same
routines every day and so if we're able
to look at that and instruct I I think
um Senator moo had said like um
replacement Behavior
that's a huge thing that I see that's
not put in you can't stop one Behavior
without giving it something else because
a behavior is a form of communication
they're trying to communicate something
you can't stop that without giving
something else more appropriate and
that's what that's what we look at so am
I correct in my understanding of what
you're saying is that some forms of
deescalation training and behavior
management um might be included in the
pilot or is it just looking at data
related to um those methods I would say
it would be Beyond just looking at the
data but in the practices I think the
data the practices in the um the um
what's the word I'm looking for make
doing it with Fidelity will say okay if
if you do this you know then you get
this but then I don't have time for this
so then it doesn't really work so making
sure you have Fidelity I think
deescalation is already there CPI is
already there I think it's almost in
every school CPI but it's still not
working so what is it that's missing
that's that's not working um one one
more is um you mentioned ABC data um
could you y what is ABC data so it's
actually setting AB setting so it's
setting anant behavior and consequence
so a setting event might be a kiddo is
on the bus and he just got bullied say
um he gets off the bus and the
antecedent is what happens right before
a behavior so the teacher says take out
your homework that's the antecedent well
the child doesn't have the homework he's
already upset about what's going on he
just wants to get out and he just slams
his hand down and says something that's
the behavior the consequence doesn't
necessarily mean a punishment it's what
H what changed in the environment so the
teacher may say say go down to the
office and that's actually what the kid
wanted he wanted to escape that feeling
right cuz it's about it's a lot about
feelings so um feelings trigger
behaviors so that would be ABC data so
you look at that and you're able very
clearly there's actually Swiss it's
called Swiss data some schools have it
it really was pretty inexpensive I want
to say it was like $300 when we used it
in lonia and you're able to track it we
were able to track in lonia that the
week before Christmas there was a huge
influx of Behavioral referrals so we put
in a targeted um intervention the week
before and boom they all went down so if
you it's it's it's like being at a
grocery store where you know if you buy
the I heard once you know the father
goes and gets beer on a Thursday night
and they put the diapers right next door
you know that's thoughtful to make
something a behavior happen and that's
kind of really what schools are like
schools are very
um Pro reactive they're not proactive
and sometimes we don't give them enough
time to be proactive
either thank you very much questions
thank you representative Cel thank you
so much and thank you for taking my
question I just want to be clear you use
the um acronym PBIS as that positive
behavior intervention systems yes so
there's two pb's there big Capital PBIS
and there's little PBIS um so big PBIS
is positive behavior interventions and
supports it's a systemic way of looking
at um behaviors throughout a school
teaching behaviors teaching appropriate
behaviors um and we've had it here I
think since 2002 throughout New
Hampshire the hard part is you get
turnover and then kind of it starts to
kind of slip away
sometimes further questions see none
thank you very much for your for your
time thank
you and um uh Cassandra Sanchez and
attorney um masso from the office of
child
advocate my
name it's rare for me
too good afternoon Cassandra Sanchez
child advocate for the State of New
Hampshire and attorney Lisa masio I am
the associate child advate and our
legislative and policy
director and we are here today in
support of House Bill
653 um as you heard before us um you
heard a bit about how we got to this
place with this bill before you today
I'm going to briefly share excuse me I'm
going to briefly share a bit about our
office um for those who may not be
familiar the office of the child
advocate is an independent impartial
state agency we are mandated with
protecting the best interests of New
Hampshire's children we have direct
oversight over our executive branch
child serving agencies in the state and
any entity that has contracted with them
for services primarily when we were
first developed our oversight was
directly over the department for
children youth and families um our child
welfare system and juvenile justice but
we have had expanded jurisdiction since
2020 which expanded us to all executive
branch child serving agencies in our
role in the state we have um certain
aspects that we are mandated through our
statute such as reviewing restraint and
seclusions for children placed in
residential facilities um this is not
inclusive of schools I want to make sure
that is very clear um and we have other
aspects of our um statute that relate to
calls coming to our office and U
managing complaints from constituents
and also looking for Trends and gaps in
our system to be able to um help close
those gaps and ensure better services to
the children across New Hampshire um so
what brought us to this bill is again
our our jurisdiction is specifically
when it comes to restraint and seclusion
over residential facilities and has not
been with schools um we have received an
influx of calls from parents over the
past couple of years with concerns for
restraints and seclusions in school of
their children um since we do not have
direct oversight or a way to review
those we do look at the aggregate
numbers that are shared through New
Hampshire Department of Education and um
we talk with schools on a one-on-one
basis dependent on the inquiry that's
come to our office and we try to further
explore and see how we're doing as a
state in reducing the restraint and
seclusion in that setting as well um
what we have found is over the years um
there's not been a drastic dip in
Restraint and seclusion numbers in our
educational settings and that has been a
concern to us and again we continue to
receive calls from families so it stays
on our radar although it is not
necessarily an aspect of our day-to-day
work it is an important issue that
directly impacts the children of New
Hampshire so with that said um we hosted
a movie screening um with the support of
Dr Ross green um in lives in the balance
and um the the name of that is the kids
we lose um very moving film documenting
the experiences that children have and
when they exhibit restraint and
seclusions in school as well as um the
difficulties that their parents face in
trying to understand and support their
child when they are not necessarily
allowed or welcomed into the school
setting um in doing that we did have an
outpouring of support and wanting to do
more to um address this
issue um to to this day we are
continuing to get phone calls from
families we got one just this week about
a 5-year-old child that has had 22
restraints in one day 5-year-old
kindergartener it's just heartbreaking
and this is what our children are
experiencing in school so we know we
need to do better we know we need more
we also understand the impact that this
has on Educators the Educators that we
have spoken to some of them have been
the ones that have called into our
office very concerned about a child in
their district and wanting to help and
do more they feel like their hands are
tied and they know that they are not
doing what's best for the child they
understand that restraints have a
negative impact and further traumatized
children but they are using the tools
that are within their toolbox right now
and a lot of that relies with that that
end result of restraint and seclusion
they will attempt to deescalate but what
we have learned is at that point it is
far too late in working and partnering
with lives in the balance and Dr Ross
Green we've learned quite a bit about
the importance of proactive approach and
what we mean by that is not waiting for
the behavior as we had just heard right
those ABCs not waiting to get to the bee
to look at addressing the issue that's
where deescalation comes in you wait for
the behavior to happen first and then
you try to deescalate the situation at
that point it's too late and so we don't
want more of the same we want our
Educators to have tools that are
different than what they already have at
their hands they already receive
restraint and seclusion training which
which already incorpor Ates deescalation
techniques we want them to have
additional tools on top of that and what
this would mean is it would give them an
opportunity to understand their students
in a different way look out for an
escalation before it is at the point of
escalation and be able to engage at that
point to help reduce the what is
happening for the child and help
stabilize the child in the entire
classroom um an example that was was
given when talking with Dr Ross Green is
an example of a child um not wanting to
move on to the next subject and what do
we see often in schools we see there
being a power struggle between the
teacher and that child getting them to
move on to that next subject is there a
way that the teacher could come to a
compromise with a child it is difficult
we know they have a curriculum that they
have to stick to but if they feel they
have tools they can do that with that
one child and continue to move on and
manage the rest of the classroom in a
successful way that's really what we're
looking to do here with this bill and
allow allowing a pilot program allows us
an opportunity to try something to see
if it works before expending a lot of
State funds on pushing out a new program
there's been a lot of programs that have
been offered in the educational realm
and as we heard and as we see on a
regular basis they're not enough they're
not working on their own and so can we
try something collect some data and see
if it's working before sharing it across
all of New
Hampshire thank you
all right I had a cough coming so she
could take it at that point uh well we
love to answer some of the questions you
all were asking which were really
fantastic questions um 126 U um is the
law that covers all this I know there
are some questions about specific
definitions it's been worked on
repeatedly there were new bills in 2023
and again uh Senator McHugh brought up
another bill last year so this is a hot
topic of conversation 12 you really does
uh contain a lot of great definitions
but again it's trying to get to that
preventative space so um and I know a
lot of the questions have been around
the specific language in the bill about
what it is to Pilot and what it is not
and really it's not intended to take
away any of the current tools it's to
make sure that if again the state is
paying for a pilot project that it's in
fact a new and different approach so
evidence-based um with those examples is
just sort of best practice of what is in
that preventative space and then what it
is not is really programs that already
exist not intending to take those
programs away but certainly not to spend
additional State funds piloting stuff
that already exists so that is why it
was worded that way um Ben Jones who's
the the policy director at lives in the
balance emailed you all um
testimony unfortunately this is Maine's
school vacation week so he was not
available to come um but he did include
some data as um both representative
patrino and Senator Miku mentioned Maine
has really been on the Forefront but he
also included uh data from Virginia to
give you sort of a look at a large
school district versus a small school
district and how that has rolled out
successfully um some of the questions
around that the different categories
again we see in our office uh calls from
all different spaces from elementary
schools some of the highest restraints
are in some of our elementary schools um
to those alternative settings so the
intent was really just to be able to
gather data from a wide swath of the
population because this is actually an
issue everywhere um but it to get a
really good uh data sample you would
need to sort of sample um and again it
is an optin program so you know
the Department of Education would put
out an RFP to find a vendor and then
schools could elect to opt in and again
last year through Senator McHugh's bill
as well as that interim study several
schools had already shown interest of
yes we have all these tools but we know
that there's more out there we would
love the opportunity to get this
training and try some new things and
there are schools that are trying new
things here and there but not in a
really systemic way that's able to
collect meaningful data to see could
truly work so it is intended to be sort
of a layered approach and really be able
to test out something new here in New
Hampshire like's been done in other
states um we did include in our
testimony a link to that documentary uh
the kids we lose you can watch it for
free on YouTube um it is really
compelling it is pretty intense um and
also the lives in the balance website
which I believe um attorney Jones
included does have a lot of really
interesting data they've worked with a
lot of different states a lot of
different types of school districts um
so we really just want to bring some of
these options to New Hampshire um you
know the calls we get from Educators it
is really stressful for them to have to
put hands on kids who are in distress uh
so really this is a tool for everybody
and and to add um we did make a note as
well in our testimony about um the
fiscal note we know the fiscal climate
this year and understand and worked
really hard um and what one of the
reasons why we
into lives in the balance is because
they have done this before and so asking
a lot of questions of how they rolled
this out and and remain fiscally
conservative and so really a lot of the
work in this bill was um intending for
the data collection to happen at the
school level to be shared out to the
districts and then from the district to
um New Hampshire Department of Education
and the vendor would be working very
closely with them to assist in analyzing
the data and in getting a report put
together so to really reduce the burden
on the New Hampshire Department of
education and put some of that on the
vendor to step up and assist with that
data collection reporting
process we are open to any other
questions you may have thank you very
much
questions represent
Freeman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in front of us um I'm just
curious have you approached any of the
individual districts with this
program yes we have spoken with some of
the districts as has um Dr Green and
lives in the B they have spoken
specifically about their program with
the districts but we have spoken to some
folks on um some of the school boards as
Lissa had mentioned um some folks at
some of the alternative residential
schools as well um and there is an
interest for more and they have voiced
feeling that they need other tools to be
able to reduce this use thank you
further
questions see none thank you very much
for your uh thorough testimony thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill
653 seeing none we'll close that hearing
and we will open the open the hearing on
House Bill uh
361 prohibiting mandatory mask policies
in
schools and um I
will I see the um Prime sponsor entering
the room on Q
and I'm sure she will give us a pink
card
later
this 36 oh right
welcome representative Noble to the
education policy committee thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee for
the record my name is Kristen Noble and
I represent the town of Bedford
Hillsboro District
2 in November of 2020 Governor sonunu
issued a mask mandate that mandate
Exempted K through 12 students teachers
and staff school boards created their
own policies for masking students
following guidance and recommendations
from the doe and
DHHS if a district decided that they
wanted to leave it to parent choice they
were free to do so to my knowledge no
one
did as time marched on parents which
includes me I was a Public School parent
at the time
we grew more frustrated with the mask
mandates because we saw that masking our
healthy children was having a negative
impact on their learning their speech
their mental and emotional well-being
their physical health and their Social
Development we voiced our concerns at
Schoolboard meetings voices that got
much louder as the months dragged on but
no one would listen and we felt helpless
there were some mask lawsuits across the
state one in my district these lawsuits
were dismissed by many as frivolous but
parents were trying everything they
could to make this stop because their
children were being
harmed students dealing with autism
anxiety asthma or learning disabilities
were not able to get exemption for these
mandates however under the governor's
mandate they would
have Co was a difficult time for all but
the response to covid was most difficult
on children a heavy burden was placed on
them to protect adults they were treated
as if they and those around them were
perpetually sick creating a climate of
fear students were repeatedly told that
they would get their family members sick
if they didn't keep their masks up they
had to wear masks in school on the bus
during gym class at recess outdoors and
even while playing instruments they cut
holes around the mouth so they could fit
the mouthpiece
in in February of 22 Governor sununu
said that school districts would no
longer be able to mandate masks and
those that continued their mandates
would be in violation of Ed 306
rules Governor sununu left it up to
local control initially but then said
they could no longer have no local
control but then he went back to local
control when he vetoed this bill two
times our local school boards didn't
have the best time during covid either
they bore the brunt of the anger and
frustration this bill protects our
school board from ever school boards
from ever being put into that situation
again I know my school board wouldn't
want a
repeat let's learn from the mistakes of
the past let's realize that there is no
decision more local than that of a
family thank
you thank you representative questions
for the
representative thank you Mr chair yes oh
sorry um thank you for taking my
question um is this is there any
difference in this bill than the bill
that was presented and that we reviewed
last year thank you for the question it
is exactly the same and thank
you represent Woodcock oh I'm
sorry thank you y thank you Mr chair and
thank you representative so this bill
does allow any student or staff member
to voluntarily wear a mask is that
correct that's correct thank you for the
questions resident
s thank you um I'm just and thank you
for taking my question um how many
districts in the state currently have
mask
mandates uh there are thank you for the
question there are none that I know of
this is to
prevent another catastrophe from
happening
again rson Paulk you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question you mentioned
that your school board doesn't want to
repeat do they support this
bill I had a thank you for the question
I had a very long talk um with my
superintendent the other day and um
he shared my thoughts and so he was
going to run it by this the
board I just haven't heard back from it
thank
you r m thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative I remember in the
discussions in previous years we had
talked about IEPs and five or four plans
does this bill exempt um students with
IEPs or five or fours a mask is required
as a part of their plan yes um thank you
for the question that's actually um the
new update that we did last year to to
the bill that was brought the previous
year so this this is a third time thanks
third times a charm
maybe yes representative U Morris yes uh
thank you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question is it true that this bill is
both reactive and
proactive thank you for the question I
think I would agree with that
yes representive Bon thank you Mr chair
um I see that there are some Provisions
for students with iaps and accommodation
plans but there don't appear to be any
provisions for uh staff members who
might have issues health issues and for
which masking around them would be
Gravely
important I thinkk you for the question
I so you're asking that children should
be mandated masks if a a staff member is
sick is that am I getting that
correct correct if you're making
accommodations for for health reasons
for students which is you know
appropriate individual but um there are
adults that work in situations that do
have health issues and being around
people that could potentially be
carrying germs could be very detrimental
to their health as
well I I think if they're free to wear a
mass themselves and if you believe that
mass work then they should be protected
my concern and and so that did come up
last last time if there was a child that
was sick in the
classroom um
I think that would be a rare
situation um and I don't
think it prevents them from asking the
parents if the kids would mask in the
classroom but I you can't mandate that
because it it did have a negative impact
on children's
learning and so I I think you can't have
a negative impact on the children
learning
experience and if if the sick child is
wearing a mask then they should be
okay further questions see none thank
you very much representative thank
you and um for the uh following um
people testifying um I'd like to limit
the testimony to three minutes if we if
we might and we'll start with
representative DeVito
yeah thank you Mr chairman and members
of the
committee my name is Sarah DeVito I am a
state rep for Rockingham District 8 and
a co-sponsor of this bill as a parent
and co-sponsor I'm writing to express or
come here and speak to you to express my
strong support for House Bill 361 which
prohibits mandatory Mass policies in
schools this bill is essential to
ensuring that parents and students have
the right to make personal health
decisions without government
mandates masking policy should be a
matter of individual choice not a
one-size fits-all requirement imposed by
the schools parents know what is best
for their children's health and
well-being and they should be able to
have that ability to decide whether the
child wears a mask during the school day
additionally prolonged maske wearing can
negatively impact students communication
Social Development and learning
experience particularly for young
children and those with special needs by
passing H Bill 361 New Hampshire will
reaffirm its commitment to parental
rights individual freedom and a balanced
approach to Public Health I urge you to
support this bill to protect students
rights and ensure that health related
decisions remain in the hands of
families not government mandates thank
you thank you very much represent Morse
uh thank you for and thank you is it
also true that um there's been a huge
increase in respiratory Health when it
comes to mandating Children long-term
use 8 hours a day same mask breathing in
and out the same exact
air I can only speak on behalf of what I
have experienced I had a child during
covid um who attended public schools and
was mandated to wear a mask and when he
would come home um especially from
playing sports the thing was filthy was
disgusting um so we would send multiple
masks for him to change throughout the
day but as a child um
you can only expect so much um plus they
would get thrown in their bags um
sometimes they would take it off for
lunch it would get thrown on the floor
it was disgusting um a lot of the time
we would end up throwing them away at
the end of the week um so yes and and he
did have a lot of respiratory um
illnesses after that just because of the
um
exposure could I get a followup yes
thank you U followup to that would be so
family
because you probably spent a pretty good
amount of money on these masks
considering the skyrocketed rates um you
know when this whole thing happened um
but lower income families that may not
have been able to afford I mean there
were masks that I saw kids using that
were the same mask for almost two weeks
straight when my child was in school
dealing with this so the added expense
to me
is lower income families couldn't afford
which
was a larger increase yeah I guess I'll
just yield
back uh any further questions yes
represent cluer thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative um I'm
wondering what you would think in the
case of um an epidemic that would maybe
hurt children such as I'll use the
measles because I remember having the
measles and it wasn't wasn't good what
would happen in that case if we
if we're putting into legislature that
we cannot mandate it but what if it did
happen that a disease like that um would
occur as a parent um and as someone in a
leadership role I would expect parents
um to use their common sense and keep
their child home if they were sick
um parents or someone like myself we
have these children and we've been
giving given these children we get to
use our own knowledge to do what we
think is right or wrong um sending a
child home um would be what I would
expect leadership at a school to do if
they noticed a child was sick send them
home rather than keep them in a in a
building full of other children that's
sick and putting a mask on them um it
just doesn't seem reasonable to me for
that so I guess my question is why would
we keep a child at school if it's sick
follow up um I think I was referring
more you know you might not know that
someone has the start of an illness and
if we know that there is an epidemic out
there that's influencing the health of
children wouldn't we want to protect
them in in that
vein I think that could go with anything
um during the winter months we know that
we're kept indoors and so the flu ramps
up um so does that mean that every
winter we should mask children I don't
think so but we could do that with any
epidemic um or any sickness um I think
the best thing is to build up our immune
system and use common sense um and keep
children sick or sick children home or
or school
officials represent McDonald thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for your work and co-sponsoring
this if there were a situations such as
an epidemic which was mentioned is it
true that this bill does not prevent the
governor or another state entity from
putting forward a mass mandate if they
sarf
it correct thank
you
repr thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
uh when the governor enacted all that in
the schools uh was there a spe specific
grade like the n95 seemed to be the
specific grade and where some of the
mass a homeade mask that were probably
less than the specific grade that were
mandated yes and I think that was one of
the main issues that people had a
problem with
is where and when do we start believing
science um I think there is written
testimony and there may be people here
that are going to speak on this that are
actually scientist or doctors that will
tell you that um with covid the paper
mask that people were wearing along with
the homemade mask made out of you know
anywhere from mesh to t-shirts to Canvas
um a lot of those didn't even stop the
particles of covid um being able to pass
back and forth so it did no good
whatsoever obviously an n95 mask would
have been ideal um but then again comes
into what rep Morse was talking about is
money who's paying for n95 mask who's
watching them to make sure that they're
changed you know they're not getting wet
they're not getting dirty um and who's
providing that is that taxpayers dollars
um so there's a whole lot of issues that
surround um the the type of mask warn
but yes
absolutely
Morris question she actually answered my
question thank you for the questions
seeing none thank you very much
representative thank you chairman and
thank you
committee uh The Honorable Arlene
cordello um welcome to the new education
committee thank you Mr chairman and
members of the education committee uh my
name is Arlene Corell I represented
Atkin
in the house last term and I was a
co-sponsor of HB 1093 which would have
prohibited school boards from mandating
maske wearing just like this bill does
it's identical as was said
previously
uh and that bill last year was passed by
both the house and the Senate but the
former Governor vetoed it his veto
message cited the importance of local
control a concept that usually make
sense in our state school districts but
this concept of local control should not
give school boards the authority to make
Health decisions for
students in fact to do so is unethical a
recent article in The Archives of
disease and childhood concluded that
recommending child masking is
unsupported by current scientific data
and inconsistent with accepted ethical
Norms when I testified last year I had a
whole bunch I had done a lot of research
I'm not going to go through that again
the fact is the house and the Senate
both passed this bill the governor
vetoed it on the issue of local control
and since that time that it was passed
um there was the release in May of the
shocking testimony of Anthony fouchi
that he had given months earlier to a
congressional subcommittee when Dr
fouchy was asked if he had followed any
of the numerous scientific studies
concerning learning loss and other
negative effects on children wearing
masks he said
no he then admitted there are a lot of
conflicting a lot of conflicting studies
I still think that's up in the
air it turns out that the
Doctor Who many had looked to for
guidance through the pandemic and who
headed an agency promoting mask use
hadn't been following the research
adequately he was further asked if there
was ever a cost benefit analysis done on
the unintended consequences of masking
Kids versus the protection that it would
give them and he answered not to my
knowledge I am now a teacher and I'll
tell you I'm seeing the effects of this
I teach middle school and these kids
were you know under these covid measures
the masks the lockdowns the social
distancing and it has scarred them I
mean I could bring up studies and all
that but I'm just saying from a personal
perspective um in my uh role now we
can't let this happen
again um I know I have three minutes I'm
I shouldn't digress from my testimony
here um so uh yeah I'll skip to this
part during the covid pandemic we
continuously heard the phrase follow the
science the science is as reflected in
the many conflicting studies that have
emerged does not provide clear
justification for mask mandates unless
the face masks are proven beyond a
shadow of a doubt to be harmless they
should never be mandated by school
boards the children should not be forced
to do something that could could
possibly cause them physical and
emotional harm we're still not sure
about these things um local school board
members are not MediCal experts and they
should not be arbitrarily mandating the
wearing of face masks the majority of
the legislature agreed on this last year
but the former Governor did
not um you know and I just have one
other thing to say I had a personal
experience this might go over can I have
an extra minute I was no all right um
anecdote aside then I will finish up
please vote OTP on HB 361 and let's give
the new governor an opportunity to sign
this bill into law and protect our
children I'll take questions thank
you
questions see none thank you very much
good to see you
again The Honorable Emily
Phillips
afternoon good afternoon uh Emily phips
uh thank you members of the committee
thank you Mr chair uh I was a sponsor of
this bill last year um and I voted for
it previously as well I just want to
give you a perspective I was on the
school board in 2019 to 2022 when the
pandemic happened and uh all we asked in
public and we among ourselves we said we
just wish the state would make this
decision because from town to town you
know we all go to the same Market Basket
but the the policies were all very
different um because the local school
boards were setting the these mask um or
face covering policies I'm from Fremont
New Hampshire and we have a pre- to8
school and we uh opened in person in
September of 2020 and we had a face
covering policy which allowed parents to
choose plastic face Shields or face
masks of any make right um so my
children had IEPs for speech and
language and other issues and so I put
them in plastic face Shields and they
went to school and I feel like I was one
of the lucky ones um all the kids right
now are very very very behind and I
think it might be a combination of the
remote learning or you know the mask or
sickness who knows but we we all know
you guys know more than anyone um how
behind our children are uh my children
didn't wear masks at school and but my
daughter specifically she's now nine is
so
emotionally stunted and um her education
is obviously um been affected greatly by
her peers wearing masks um she didn't
speak at all and until uh second grade
so um she was just I don't know if it
was anxiety or what it was but she was
four when the pandemic happened and uh
she was already very speech delayed and
then she just never spoke um I ended up
pulling her out in homeschooling um
after a year of being there with um all
of her peers wearing masks all of her
speech and language Pathologists
covering their facei trying to teach her
how to speak um it very frustrating from
a parental point of view um that people
who are elected who are are not
qualified to make Health decisions we
don't let our school boards decide which
vaccines are required or other things
but we arbitrarily allowed for the sake
of local control School boards to set
these policies and all we're asking is
that the state whether it be the elected
legislature here or the governor to
decide these things if it should be if
it is warranted in future pandemics or
what have you let you guys decide let
the governor decide not elected
Schoolboard people we don't want the
burden I mean actually running for
school board now we don't want to make
these decisions we have a lot more
important work to do at the local level
than to fight with parents because it's
very divisive right we don't want to
fight we have other more important
things to do let's get back to the
basics of Education about yes about um
you know what's most important at the
school level so we're just asking for
the state to do this because it is a
burden on school boards to set these
policies thank you very much any
questions representative Bon thank you
Mr CH and thank you for taking my
question um you mentioned that you were
on a local board I know that the boards
in a lot of towns in my SE area they
relied on the um the recommendations of
the public health officers in the town
and the transmission Rats of the
community uh using that information to
make the local decisions was that also
the case with your board sure but like I
said we the towns right next to us were
requiring everyone to wear face masks we
didn't have that policy there was one
moment where we mandated masks during a
high outbreak period I want to say like
four or five months in and it was a twoe
period where everyone had to wear masks
unless you were covered by a disability
or an IEP um but other than that we were
we allowed choice now most people just
did The Masks homemade or whatnot
um so yeah we we could pivot and change
but as you know we're all shopping at
the same places the the it's just like
mosquitoes right they travel to the next
yard I mean we're it's funny that one
District right next to another District
can arbitrarily make different decisions
we had teachers who were trying to pull
their kids out of their Hometown to go
to our school because we were physically
open and her school wasn't but she had
to teach at our school so it's just like
we're all one big Community here in New
Hampshire so let's just we're not that
big we're not Texas we're not California
um if this needs to be done let it be
done on the on the executive level of
the state not through elected
bureaucrats at our local level I mean
everything else is fine but this is a
health ordinance and if we're talking
about local control the AL the ultimate
local control is app
parents thank you see no further
questions thank you very much for being
back in
education Dr Gary
York thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Gary orc I
live in Hopkinton New
Hampshire uh to me this was a no-brainer
legislation this is passed before in
this in this state uh I think I think if
we all accept the premise that masks do
not work then all these other Arguments
for what if this what if that all that
it it doesn't matter if they don't work
then it's just political theater if you
want to have people wearing
masks it's very
simple um I remember testifying three
years ago uh with uh Industrial Engineer
specializing hygiene talking about how
ineffective they were that was three
years ago U representative Morris
mentioned this is a proactive thing well
it was proactive three years ago and
it's high time to get this thing done so
if you don't realize that masks don't
work then uh maybe find another news
source or whatever
but here's here's here's a source this
is Alan steo he writes substack which is
a alternate new
source uh Alan steo from Lockdown land
he's written a book face mask in one
lesson pretty thick book yes uh it's out
there his second book because his first
one was so popular face masks hurt kids
and this is a much thicker book and he
has 43 pages of references and small
print of why they don't work so if we
accept that mass don't
work this is Nob brainer
legislation thank you very much
questions
seeing none thank you very much for
being here
again Samantha
moris thank
you um hello chairman and
representatives my name is Samantha
Morse and I'm the newly elected Register
of Deeds for marac County I'm here today
to urge you to support HB 361 as a
parent I've experienced firsthand the
Heartbreak of sending my child to school
in tears due to mask
mandates every day I had to reassure my
5-year-old at the time in having just
started school that it would be okay and
he could take his mask off as soon as he
got home my son would come home day
after day with his mask taped to his
face on his cheeks um because the school
issued masks didn't fit properly which
caused some irritation uh not only in
those areas that were taped but around
his ears and it made him it made it
difficult for him to
breathe uh he also uh couldn't wear
glasses comfortably because the mask
would fog up the glasses I have that
issue myself too um had my child fainted
or worst case died to the lack of air
flow educating staff members would
forever have that on their conscience to
have proper air flow the mouth and the
nose need to be exposed
somehow who would have been liable in
this worst case
scenario the situation became so
distressing that we told our child to
only wear the mask over his mouth if he
was having trouble breathing however
this was still problematic because
children are often afraid to stand up to
authority figures even if they're
uncomfortable they may have privileges
taken away if they don't follow the
rules mind you those rules or mandate
were only applied indoors though my
child was stillar wearing a mask on the
jungle gym during recess time
furthermore the use of masks with
patterns that appeal to children didn't
change the fact that they were still
restricting air flow the whole
experience was traumatic for my child
and did not set him up for success in
the future for these reasons I urge you
to support hb36 uh HB 361 and protect
the health and well-being of our
children thank you thank you very much
for being here represent Murray thank
you Mr chair and just for the record I
just want to make sure you had uh
announced that you were the newly
elected regist of Deeds you were but you
were here testifying in your personal
capacity is that correct
correct see no further questions thank
you very much for coming in
today Moren Hardy
thank you very much for allowing me to
testify today my name is Moren Hardy I'm
from London Derry I'm testifying in
favor of this bill um as for um
introduction I have worked in the
clinical microbiology laboratory for 26
years I participated in the infection
control task group for my Hospital
including Ambulatory Care settings I've
worked in research and um development
for Diagnostic devices for infectious
diseases and I've worked in the Pharma
industry and pharmacovigilance I have
taught clinical microbiology at the
community college level and medical
ethics at the University level I have a
M's in
epidemiology when evaluating a a medical
intervention or public health mitigation
strategy for a disease whether from the
perspective of a device like a mask or a
public health policy the risk benefit
analysis must be
considered um based on multiple studies
and population data the risk benefit
analysis does not support support the
use of facial masks for the prevention
of respiratory viruses including SARS
cope 2 especially for children I have
provided you the pack it's at the
beginning of the packet there's a link
to
170 studies and journal
articles that show that masks do not
work and also discuss the damage to
Children done by masks there's um
longitudinal cohort cohort um rcts and
observational studies to support my
positions there was even a cohort cohort
study of
kindergarteners um there's plenty in
your packet to look
through um wearing masks is not a benign
intervention and causes serious and
potentially long-term damage to Children
mask wearing causes physical
psychological and social damage to
children we know that masks encourage
mouth breathing breathing in children
which leads to facial deformities masks
interfere with Children Learning
socially through facial expressions
speech learning is delayed in the very
young learning deficit have been
observed in all age groups an Israeli
Canadian study published in cognitive
research in February 2022 found that
face masks face masks disrupt holistic
processing and face perception in school
age children masks keep other pathogens
trapped near the mouth and nose in the
lungs of children these are larger
pathogens and include bacteria mold and
parasites bacterial counts increase
linearly with wearing
duration another important drawback of
face masks and children may well be that
their use could reduce the focus from
other measures that may be more
important such as handwashing and
staying home when they are sick children
are a vulnerable group that would face
the longest and thus most profound
consequences of potentially risky mask
use um citation 13 includes a table of
27 Adverse Events when using masks and
finally uh um children need to be free
to be exposed to the natural environment
to keep their immune systems uh one size
fits all solutions do not work when it
comes to your health many people assume
that because they are able to wear a
mask without issue everyone including
children should be able to wear a mask
without issue there are numerous reasons
why someone might not be able to wear a
mask respiratory conditions such as
asthma and COPD anxiety or other
psychological issues and disorders
autism or other developmental disorders
hearing
impairments PTSD from being a victim of
rape or sexual assault or another
violent crime in which the perpetrator
was wearing a face covering or Force the
victim to wear a face covering sensory
issues and disorders and skin conditions
like staff infections yeast infections
contact dermatitis therefore the risk
benefit analysis does not support the
use of facial masks as a medical
intervention or public health mitigation
strategy especially for school children
there's questionable if you could wrap
up I just have the but okay you can
always just summarize that and you can
hand it in The Mask recommendations were
put in into place by national and local
public health agencies without benefit
evidence of benefit and without
evaluation of risks and were followed by
school boards and administrators who had
no other sources or guidance we now have
2020 hindsight and understand that
masking children is wrong let us correct
this now and not put the school boards
in the position of having to mandate bad
policy ever
again leave it with that thank you very
much
questions thank you very much for uh all
the uh information and if if you would
care to hand that written testimony into
our clerk we we can put that in the
record as well that in this room here
just right over here just hand it to
anyone there anarie Banfield
good afternoon for the record an Mar
Banfield I'm a parental rights Advocate
focused on excellence and education in
New Hampshire um I normally don't share
information about myself too much but
some of you may know this some of you
may not um I'm a kidney kidney
transplant recipient of about 15 years
ago so I'm immune compromised and for
many many years I had to deal with um
viruses
obviously uh I did choose to wear a mask
uh mainly on airplanes because I wasn't
sure somebody sitting next to me would
be would carry up be carrying um a virus
or
something uh that's kind of why I was
kind of shocked by the response when
covid came along because people like me
have been dealing with with this forever
I mean flu comes along I have to be
careful you know those kind of things my
doctor my nephologist really emphasized
handwashing not even masks I just chose
to wear one on the plane sometimes if it
was during cold and flu
season um so when this occurred you know
I was very sympathetic to parents who
wanted their kids masked you know we
didn't know I mean I'm listening to this
going holy crap why am I wearing a mask
I mean I'm very good about washing my
hands I get off the airplane and it
didn't matter if I wore a mask cuz if I
pick something up on the air take the
mask off and it's on my hand doesn't
matter that I was wearing a mask so I'm
very sympathetic though to people who
wear and I don't I don't think they
should be shamed I think if a parent
wants their child in mask so be
it um
but the the mandates the force because I
thought well I never forced anybody on a
plane to wear a mask I chose to wear one
and I did that for years so I wasn't
sure why this was being you know
mandated in this way so he supported the
parents who on their children mask but
then I was also hearing from parents who
were like you know my child's
neurodiverse I can't get up a mask on
their on their face
um emotional issues that I was not
familiar with because I can put one on
but then I'm hearing from them thinking
this is this is serious like some of
these parents cannot force their kids to
do this I can remember with my son the
tag in the back of his shirt he couldn't
walk around with a tag in the back of
his shirt so imagine putting it on his
face um
so I think it's just common sense to let
the parents basically decide I do I mean
I know that that the governor would
still have you know the the position to
require mandates but Schoolboard members
don't have a medical background I would
assume that a a governor or or a state
body would be bringing in medical advice
on this I get my medical advice from my
doctor I'm not going to the school board
and having them tell me if I should mask
my child or not and to be honest with
you I might have masked my child for a
little while during covid but that would
have been my choice working with the
doctor I would have asked the doctor or
my daughter who is a pediatric nurse I
would asked her you know is this
necessary these kind of things um it's
three minutes up okay then I'm going to
just stop right there okay okay great
thank you questions for Miss
bfield thank you see none thank you very
much Aubrey
freedan Mr chairman committee members
Aubrey Friedman I live in Bridgewater I
speak in support of this bill um of
course it should be up to the parents
not school bureaucrats who like 99% of
the time they just defer to the health
authori so when they say Lo local
control it wasn't that they're just
deferring to the you know D HHS or
whatever they didn't uh really they
didn't know any more than we did so our
experience in SAU 4 it was a disaster
for close to a year we fought and there'
be the people who wanted them again it's
not the mask it's the mask mandate
that's the problem and the people who
wanted the Mandate they sat on one ins
side of the auditorium with their masks
on and they cited all the studies saying
that the mask masks make a difference
and then the anti-maskers we sat on the
other side because we didn't want to
infect them we had our own studies
saying that they they're not effective
or there's it's
inconclusive spent almost a whole school
year I believe till about March finally
the Mandate was dropped and then and for
all that time fighting about a bunch of
nonsense rather than worrying about a
raising our academic uh literacy of the
kids that's what the schools are
supposed to be for we were fighting
about this and then soon as the Mandate
was dropped uh hardly anybody wore a
mask after that nobody cared if you did
so it was a big waste of time and I
might add this might be a good argument
for having uh more uh access to efas and
school choice because this doesn't
affect private schools so for those
parents who want to make everybody wear
a askk they could choose a school that a
private school that would have that
mandate and that'd be fine for them that
everybody more choices better for
everybody maybe we can stick to the bill
oh okay yeah so um I I support the bill
and let's not go through this mess again
and and not have any mask mandate keep
it optional and that's it thank you
thank you very much any
questions see none thank you very much
for coming
down and and Nancy
Beerman nany Beerman New Boston I am a
member of the New Hampshire rare disease
advisory Council but I'm speaking for
myself saw some of you down in the
cafeteria rare disease day February 28th
make sure you uh wear your zebra stripes
had to plug that in um I'm also a parent
and a teacher of 15 years and going into
teaching y all knew you were going into
the petri dish um you were going to
catch everything and anything uh if you
did not know that you had poor schooling
going into education um my first two
three years of teaching we caught
everything um my second year of teaching
chickenpox went through the school what
are you going to do nothing else you can
do but clean the desks and make sure the
kids are you know coming to school and
all of a sudden like my tummy itches off
they went to the nurse um through Co my
daughter has um a hearing issue and uh
it was hard enough uh to get the adults
the teachers to wear the clear mask so
she could see their face um she needs to
read their lips and um teachers refused
um so that impaired her ability to learn
uh and it didn't matter if it was in our
504 plan or not nobody listen um in
kinderg I taught kindergarten for 5
years they need to see your face they
need to see what your face is doing what
your lips are doing that's how how you
taught letter sounds look the way my
mouth is look where my tongue is look
what my tongue is doing I you can't do
that with a mask on um and then you know
as far as a teacher I mean I was
pregnant with my first child in teaching
and I had a parent that came in and said
oh my goodness my kid has fists disease
and as people that have had children and
been in the teaching field and know
fists disease is very prevalent in the
school district and I knew that too um
thankfully I was far enough in my
pregnancy that affect me but that's a
risk I took I knew that going in um you
know just be aware I mean when I hear
people talking about people in the
medical field oh they didn't know yeah
you do you know you're going to get in
contact with everything and anything you
don't know what's going to walk through
the door and as a teacher you don't know
what's going to walk through the door um
and as far as measles three cases is um
considered an epidemic my college in
1992 had our best Quil team got the
measles from another team and that's
when they decided to give everyone a
second shot of MMR
um and I oh and then my finally my
oldest child uh they had chickenpox when
she was in high school went through and
she's type 1 diabetic so autoimmune
compromised and so we kept her there and
I said well we'll see if the vaccine
worked or not and if and it she didn't
catch it but if she didn't we would just
deal with it so you know that as a
parent your kids are going to come in
contact with stuff it's all good that's
it thank you very much questions
concerns questions for the than all
right thankk you very much no problem
where you representative
poena but I'm not Italian it's my
husband so I am Italian oh I know you
are rip Freeman I love her accent okay
so for the record thank you Mr chair um
uh representative Penza uh straford
District 19 that's Rochester WS 1 2 3 4
and six so I'm not going to take your
time you've heard my testimony probably
um representative cordelli I don't know
maybe what four times now um this bill
has come forward and it has passed uh
twice both bodies and here we are again
so three times needs to be a charm um my
family suffered
greatly my daughter has anxiety could
never wear a mask tried to get an
exemption from her from from her uh her
therapist it didn't matter it was it was
like disabilities just didn't exist
anymore um and I actually um left public
school to go to a private school and
they were just as ridiculous so after
about 3 months had to pull out my kids
because a teacher threatened my daughter
to say there would be dire consequen
put her hand on her face and pulled the
mask over her
nose I have stories that could go on for
for hours and you don't want to hear
them so let's just get this done um it
needs to happen it it severely harmed my
oldest daughter in so many ways
disruptions in her
education and um and created her level
of anxiety just went through the roof
and um so for all of those reasons
parents know their kids best and um and
if there is some sort of Statewide
emergency and the governor has that um
perview to do that that's fine but
school board members are they're not
doctors and they're not parents of your
children and um please do the right
thing and vote ought to pass on this
thank you thank you for being here any
questions see none thank you very
much I believe that is the last
testimony we have on House Bill
361 oh I'm sorry I missed I missed your
card
ranchester I won't close the hearing
thank you committee chair thank you
committee chair thank you committee
members um I have a long history of
working with abused and neglected
children
and never okay that is never okay
discrimination is discrimination
children who have been abused and
neglected should be a protected
class and putting a mask over someone's
mouth when they're a child a traumatized
child should never ever ever be
okay the kind of feeling that an adult
gets when they see a
child like that should put something in
your heart that says that is not
okay the Department of Education the
school boards they understand
academics let's put it back where it
belongs there isn't a there isn't a
social service person
alive that understands the importance of
valuing an abused and neglected child
and masking is never okay thank you and
I'll take any questions thank you very
much any
questions see none thank you very
much so now we will close the hearing on
House Bill
361 and we will um open the hearing on
House Bill 360 which is prohibiting
public schools from performing
diagnostic tests or surgical procedures
or prescribing pharmaceutical
drugs and the prime sponsor is uh here
again representative Noble thank you
very
much okay um could you hold on for one
second yeah
right we're just going to uh switch
clerks thank you
I emailed her yesterday she has okay
thank
you
what 360 yeah
for 361
ready
yes you all set okay thank you very much
um we're all set representative Noble if
you
are thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee for the record I'm Kristen
Noble I represent Hillsboro District 2
the town of
Bedford so how did this bill come
about last term we had a work session um
in this committee on mental health and
it prompted me to do some research on
Mental Health in schools and that is
when I discovered school-based Health
Centers
this would be like having a doctor's
office right in the school offering
Primary Care Mental Health Services
reproductive health schoolwide health
education immunizations laboratory
services substance abuse services and
more it does seem to vary from state to
state um what is offered for
services who would have access to the
Health Center mostly
students but I have also seen staff um
but could also be student families or
community members and I think it
probably depends on how close they are
to the Community Schools model this is
something that the CDC had promoted
called whole school whole Community
whole child where your local public
school would serve the entire Community
such as offering adult education classes
or health care
services School based Health Centers
have been around for
decades there are thousands across the
country in New Hampshire I believe we
have four that have started I know in
Manchester um they're very focused on
mental health and I'm not sure if the
grant they just received is um if they
are planning to expand on those
Services uh I'm not sure what the others
in the state are offering
um how are these Health Centers funded
typically they start with grants in
December the US Department of Education
was offering grants for districts to set
up full service Community
Schools I don't know what the details of
those grants are the rest of the funding
also seems to vary from state to
state what is common in all I believe is
that they're billing Medicaid and
private insurance where they can and
then supplementing with State funding
Local District funding and sometimes
partnering um with a charitable
Foundation this bill is aimed at
stopping our schools from turning into
Health Care
Centers why would I want to do that
healthc care is not the purpose of our
Public Schools our schools are for
educating
children I'm very concerned about the
funding when grant grant money runs out
that's when things usually fall to the
local taxpayers too many Granite Staters
have hit their limit where property
taxes are
concerned mistakes could happen and it
is a concern of children having medical
appointments without a parent
present Tiffany cck from um Health
Freedom Maine sent me some testimony she
wasn't able to be here today and I think
I'm going to share it with you because
it it does have some important
information of what's going on in
Maine my name is Tiffany CRA I'm one of
your neighbors from Maine and I'm well
she's not here today to testify but
she's hoping you vote to pass HB
360 I am the executive director of
Health Choice main we work to protect
medical freedom and parental rights
currently representing over 6,000
families across Maine currently in Maine
there are over 30 school-based Health
Centers and the State's goal is to open
another 15 in the next 18 months most of
the clinics currently in Maine were
approved and put in quietly under the
cover of covid lockdowns there are
thousands of parents in Maine right now
that still have no idea that a third
party Medical Clinic is in their child's
school or whether their child is receive
receiving or has received Medical
Care these clinics are now in districts
across Maine in high schools and in
elementary schools some districts are
even opening them in both Elementary and
high schools these clinics are not part
of or being held accountable to the
school districts rather they are operate
operating as auxiliary clinics managed
by Major Hospital
networks the services offered can range
from Minor Medical Care to fully
functional Diagnostic and prescription
capabilities even the approach to a
specific service can vary for example
all Clin all clinics offer sexual health
and reproductive Health Services which
include birth control
prescriptions however we have found
several clinics
offering nlex neplexon implants and IUD
birth control devices without even
parental knowledge let alone
consent because of the legal support and
individual advocacy we offer families we
have had a front row seat to the harm
being done as a result of these clinics
in fact we are actively pursuing
litigation in one situation where a
young lady was being seen treated
diagnosed and medicated at school
without parental knowledge for almost 3
years when this girl's friend group
decided to go to the clinic and get
birth control she felt compelled to go
along so she wouldn't be the odd one out
that first year she was given oral birth
control she was not however educated
about the birth control she was being
given at all not even the basic informed
consent that is standard care she was
simply given pills and told to take them
the following year she was preemptively
directed by the clinic staff to choose
between an NE plexon implant or an IUD
she chose the implant several of her
friends however chose iuds after being
given the implant she was told to
continue oral birth control as well
when she asked why she was told it would
regulate her periods even though
irregular periods was not something she
was being seen for on top of this the
clinic was also providing Plan B pills
prophylactically which she took on a
couple different occasions as directed
by the clinic so by the time the next
school year started this girl had been
on multiple birth controls her hormones
were wrecked and she was showing
symptoms of such yet when she went back
to the Clinic to explain what was going
on they simply diagnosed her with
clinical depression and prescribed her
an
SSRI maybe maybe could concentrate on
the
bill okay it this is what was going on
in school based Health Clinic thank
you and if you could if that's written
you could sub that also
okay so at the risk of stating the
obvious this is dangerous what is worse
is that we are pursuing litigation we
are finding just how unaccountable these
clinics are which just amplifies the
danger the family in our case was lucky
while harm was done it can mostly be
healed in time and proper with time and
proper treatment but what happens to the
family who isn't so lucky what happens
when a young girl suffers a serious
injury from an IUD no one knows she got
or to a young boy who dies after being
prescribed medication that he couldn't
take so I'll stop there and and share
that with with the committee
so if you take a look at the um language
of the bill it was my intention to come
today with a with an
amendment um however I probably would
have have drafted like five amendments
by now so I figured I'll wait and see
what what comes out of the hearing and
just do
one um so the when I was putting in the
bill I W I was confused about if this
was going to stop the the normal things
that happen in school with like the
vision and the hearing and the things
that they've been doing for forever um
or or any other um screenings
but that's they're actually screenings
it's not a diagnostic test so it
wouldn't be stopped by this
bill um when when Diana Fenton came in
and gave us that little training on on
the law book she had pointed out a
section in the law as a good example of
how to exclude things or to say this um
this should not be meant to include so I
will have a list I actually have a
couple of lists um I asked the special
ed director um in my town if she could
provide me a list with all the things
that they're doing for screening so that
I make sure everything is
covered
um and also Becky Wilson has he she sent
me some stuff yesterday
too the first thing that um people were
concerned about when they read this is
that their school nurse would not be
able to do their
job
um
the pro diagnostic testing surgical
procedures or prescribing pharmaceutical
drugs is not within the scope of
practice of an RN and I believe that
most School nurses are
RN's and the other thing around the
nurse is um you know they they are
administering medication
diabetes was brought up a lot and
so they they'd be testing um their blood
sugar during the day potentially and so
people were concerned that they wouldn't
be able to do that the diagnostic
testing was actually already done by The
Physician to come up with the diagnosis
of diabetes so the nurse at that point
is really just following what's from the
doctor's plan she's doing it's really
just an assessment and then she would
adjust the child's insulin if if needed
or administer insulin if
needed I'm trying to think
else lots of things came up um taking
temperature blood pressure
um you know all of those things are are
part of a a nursing assessment so the
the normal things that she would do in
school it's an assessment and then that
assessment leads to a nursing diagnosis
which is not a
diagnosis so she um the school nurse is
is covered and I did so I heard from
someone who was really concerned about
that and she had emailed me back a few
days later and said nope my you're good
my school nurse says it's fine and she
has gave me a whole explanation of stuff
which I can share with everybody and
there's actually online testimony as
well from from a school nurse that's it
just doesn't touch me at
all so
there I definitely need to change some
wording um I am considering changing
diagnostic test to perhaps some medical
diagnosis um and then
also probably changing
School physician because they're not
actually employed by the
school
and I think that's about it so really
this is
all based on trying to stop our schools
from turning into Health Care
Centers happy to take any questions
thank
you represent of
Hall thank you for taking my question
I'm just curious a lot of your testimony
was about Main in New Hampshire you said
there were four centers right now did
you say that one Manchester and is that
I so Becky Wilson told me there was one
in
Newport I I don't know exactly what the
services are that they're providing I
think there might be one in Nashua and I
forget the fourth but I think there
might be somebody here that knows follow
up
follow are they experiencing any of
those your concerns in this bill I have
not heard but
this bill is more preventative
than thank you further questions see
none oh I see representative Freeman has
a question thank you um Mr chair and
thank you um representative for taking
my question so based on this bill and
some of the conversations I've had with
people concerning this bill
um do you know if um every time you were
your child visit it's a doctor that you
have to sign a form that let you know
that what your hippo rights are and you
given them permission to the insurance
company to build your insurance and
you're responsible for any money after
that do you know if these Community
School centers have the same type of um
I don't want to say paperwork but the
same type of administrative
tasks thank you for the
question there they do get um there is
Parental con consent I think um because
from state to state especially for like
birth control and maybe substance abuse
Services I think that the the the age is
is different from state to state
um but yes parental consent is part of
it I don't know if they're doing one or
if they're doing it for every
service thank you MH
for the questions represent Paul Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so I'm curious how are these
set up how does the school district and
the health care center how does that
healthc care center get into the school
do they like ask a school board to go to
the town well how does that
work I actually don't um I'm not sure
how it comes about okay I've never heard
of it that's like yeah oh yeah thank
you represent B
bony oh thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um so these
community health centers that are set up
in the schools the people that work for
the community health centers are these
people School Personnel that work there
no it's
um typically they're partnering with
like a a a health care um company or
facility followup yes um so the the
place where this bill is located is
under School Health mhm um so I I
wouldn't think that this would have
anything to do with schools if there not
the school district providing the
services it's happening within the
school and so that's why it's in that
section r s thank you um thank you for
taking my question in in one of my um
previous jobs I worked for an
organization that provided Community
Health Services
which included um offering dental care
for children who didn't have the means
to get dental care and so they would
partner with school districts to be able
to help provide Dental Care to those
children at school with yes there is and
please don't interrupt me that's not
your purview it's you um so my question
is how this bill would impact
organizations like that that are going
in at the behest of the community who
are saying to these Health Centers and
health organiz we don't have the
resources to provide this care for our
children you have that ability how would
this make it so that those Partnerships
would no longer be able to
occur I only just found out that that
was going on
um I I think that's something I need to
think about
and maybe add to the
amendment I I don't I'm not sure is it
only cleanings that they're doing um m
yes respond thank you well yeah you can
ask the questions and she can do the
answers
right to clarify I could have asked you
they they provided uh dental care and
and they would reach out to parents if
there was more than just a a screening
or cleaning needed but so that was one
of their purposes as a Community Health
Organization and so I'm wondering about
the possibility of blocking community
health organizations being able to
provide the support requested by the
Community uh represent Freeman did you
have a question I did thank you Mr chair
um representative have you heard about
the new school that they will be
building in Manchester and um what one
of the functions of that new elementary
school will
be I know that they were awarded a grant
I think in December so I would assume
that it would be they would have a
clinic or healthc Care
Center follow follow would you believe
um representative that um the new school
didn't get a grant actually but um that
one of the functions of that new
elementary school would be uh to be a
community health center yes I would
believe thank you
um Just for future reference you know
this is to solicit testimony so really
what would you believe is not a a valid
question in in Community Committee
hearing yes represent
Morris okay
um any further questions thank you very
much
representative Aubrey fredman
[Music]
uh Mr chairman committee members Aubrey
Friedman Liv in Bridgewater I speak in
support of this bill too uh even hearing
that the uh if I could ask you to pause
for one second we'll do three minutes
for this hearing as well if you would
yeah yeah I'll make it quick um I I
still support it because I I think she's
not going to change the basic intent
which is our schools are increasingly
becoming like hospitals and that that is
a problem there's supposed to be schools
let's have them be schools again not
hospitals they've gotten away they're
not doing such a great job on the
academic so I have more distracting
things going on at school and so that's
the real problem and it's also that um
parents are shirking away from their
responsibilities to take care of their
kids when uh my son was growing up and I
did it as a single parent I always took
him to his appointment a parent should
be there when your kid is having
anything medical done I scheduled
appointments late in the afternoon so he
wouldn't even be missing school it's not
uh taking away from the day you know the
school day and where I'd miss the
minimal and you uh you should be there
when your kid is having anything medical
done that's the problem is that people
are just uh uh well the school will take
care of all that and I don't need to be
there and um you know you do know about
like the vaccinations uh that happened
by mistake and uh so that's one thing
right there and also about the uh the
Hippa law a 12-year-old girl could
request a birth control uh device put in
and if it's going to be at school the
parents wouldn't even know and the
school because of the Hippa law they
don't have to reveal that that actually
would well maybe I'm wrong on that okay
but that's what I've heard a 12-year-old
girl uh and if they do these things at
school the parents wouldn't know so I
think we need to get back to schools
being schools again and not being a
hospital or a medical center just
distracts from the original
Mission that's it thank you very much
questions see none do you have a
question
okay thank you thank
you Steven
scare good afternoon chairman cordella
and distinguished members of the
committee Steven scare
NASA I support this bill as a necessary
step in limiting the school's roles in
medically and socially transitioning CH
children
I'm an activist trying to prevent
children from being exploited through
gender
ideology um my concern is that these
clinics have a role in that while I was
sitting here I sent a message to my
friend Jaimie Reid who worked at a
gender clinic in St Louis and she's in
the opposite um political spectrum and
the political spectrum that I am and I
asked her her opinion that she she ended
up being a whistleblower in that clinic
and she responded to me she with schools
by the way as part of this job in
Missouri we had a number of school-based
Health Centers and yes they are part of
the erosion of parental rights and
oversight to Medical Care access by
teens primarily they are set up to
provide birth control mental health
medications and some routine Medical
Care to kids directly in schools where
they go arai is they set up a
relationship with the teens outside of
the parental oversite in many states
teens can consent for birth control
without parents consent and needed and
they also been extending gender
affirming care into the same realm that
they placed B birth control and in
Oregon I saw they're already doing that
they're they're writing referrals for
surgeries and um prescriptions for
cross- sex hormones I'm also a little
concerned because we already know our
public schools are secretly affirming
children's gender identity which are
entirely imaginary constructs no one can
disprove them or affirm them they're
based on stereotypes and circular reason
in and two years ago Dr Simon ball of
Dartmouth Health talked about testifying
to the Health and Human Services
committee If the parents aren't
affirming the children then parents
should the children should be um turning
to other trusted adults until schools
including schools so I'm I'm strongly
against making schools part of what I
see as a very very destructive and
harmful pattern of exploitations of
children thank you very much
represent moris uh thank you Mr thank
you for taking my question did I hear
you right when it sounded like you said
that uh some of these clinics were
providing puberty blockers to students
without parental consent if I said
puberty blockers and I misspoke it is in
Portland Oregon cross sex hormones and
um letters of referral for momies and
their laws are such that if a
16-year-old girls decides I want to get
a myectomy because I have a male gender
identity she can go ahead and get that
and then her parents will get the bill
for the
surgery be clear you're talking about
another state not New Hampshire
correct that's correct yes okay thank
you any further
questions see none thank you very much
for being
here um and uh Beth scare maybe someone
you know
my name is Beth scare my grandmother
from nashwa and I'm here supporting
hb36 School clinics are overstepping
their bounds when they prescribe
medications perform invasive diagnostic
tests or perform surgeries that type of
Health Care should only be provided in
medical set settings outside of school
Under the supervision of a child's
parent or Guardian
a student in Maine was sent home from
school with a baggie of
anti-depressants female students in
Pennsylvania received pelvic exams at
school Under duress and against their
parents wishes a student in Maryland
receiv received received a birth control
implant in her arm at school which
requires surgery against her mother's
wishes none of this should be happening
and the spill would help protect kids
from experiencing this in New Hampshire
please vote out to pass on hb3 360 to
protect New Hampshire
kids thank you very much any questions
represent Woodcock thank you thank you
my question do you have any direct
references for those uh could you s them
to the committee have in Reading where
they came from thank you you
welcome further questions see none thank
you very
much representative Potenza were you
interested in speaking on this
bill um yeah your card says 361 but yeah
sorry yeah why
not uh thank you Mr chair for the record
again um representative Kell Penza
straford District
19 um I strongly support this bill um I
can't even imagine those things
happening I have two teenage daughters
um any of those things happening without
my knowledge um or care being involved
one of the main reasons why I support
this bill has a lot to do with um during
the pandemic and I will uh provide this
information to the committee this bill
hasn't come forward in the sense that
I've ever testified on something similar
so actually it's another representative
now we both ran together and she's in
Milton and we went she asked me to come
testify at a school board meeting about
just some spe uh specific like Esser
grants and certain things like that just
to give them
um the school board some information and
we walked in we we were in the
Schoolboard meeting and then there was a
there was like a break we came out in
the hallway and on a table they were
doing um
vaccinations there was no one there and
there were vials and needles just out
there and a whole group of students
playing basketball in the gym I thought
I was like in an an opposite world and
this is where we really the another
testimony said schools need to be
schools why can't we go back to that I
don't want to you know age myself here
but you know I graduated high school in
in
1991 um and I I can't imagine any of
this like why aren't we getting back to
the basics why aren't we supporting good
teachers why aren't we teaching you know
Reading Writing math arithm what are we
doing like we're going down such a such
a wrong path let parents do what they
need to do in their own and if there is
a need for community health clinics
those are all happening right now you
can get everything that you want by
walking into a a CVS or a Walgreens and
all of that there's so much that's
available that I never had available um
when I was young as well so I just
really hope that um the committee looks
at these things and I will send uh those
pictures and that story I think it got
published in a couple different articles
we were we were it was representative
Burnham and I and we were quite
horrified we literally could have
grabbed that it was the vials everything
it was um we just we need to have
medical professionals be doing what
they're be what they should be doing in
their places and then we need Educators
fantastic Educators doing what they
should be doing in their places and
let's keep that separate thank you thank
you uh any questions for the
representative see none thank
you Melissa
BL thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm Melissa blasik I'm here
representing rebuild NH I just want to
kind of Rapid Fire answer some questions
um that didn't get answered before so I
would recommend amending this bill to
say specifically medical diagnosis that
is legally different than nursing
diagnosis um what nurses do in school
currently is is it in the scope of
nursing diagnosis as opposed to medical
diagnosis um the clinics in New
Hampshire are very new we're talking
matter of months old so there's not a
lot of information about them yet we
really have a unique opportunity we we
are the last state in the country to get
school-based health clinics and we have
a um a real opportunity to kind of look
around and see what's happening in other
states and put some roadblocks and
barriers up here before it really takes
hold because right now we have four
clinics it's not a lot right um yes the
Manchester School the new one is a
school-based health clinic school
because it's replacing an existing one
and dental screenings and cleanings
would be fine under this law um you
wouldn't be able to do further dental
work but you could do a screening and
and uh refer out for you know more work
um and uh you could do cleanings um okay
so I didn't know anything about
school-based health clinics until last
year there was a bill in the Senate and
it was to create an entire legal
framework for school based health
clinics
now currently they are neither legal nor
illegal if that makes sense there's
nothing there's no statute that sort of
creates a legal framework for them so
they sort of just op operate a little
willy-nilly if I'm being honest um that
build did die and I started doing a lot
more research on them this is not like
your vaccine Clinics of old okay it is
not where the school nurse just rolls in
and does a treatment that's a treatment
by the way so that's still allowed under
the spill um these are fullscale
diagnostic clinics um and a they are all
slightly different it depends on what
they've chosen to do but they have the
ability to be fullscale diagnostic um
and surgical units if they want to be um
and that does happen in different parts
of the country they do minor surgeries
um so these are third-party clinics we
are opening up public schools and
offering private corporations unlimited
access to an incredibly vulnerable
population children who are there
without their parents the state and
locality should not be in the business
of lining pockets of Corporations at the
expense of children
parental consent yes parental consent
would be required but there is no
standardization of how that consent is
given so to answer representative
Freeman's question before some of them
do operate where the parent just signs a
blanket form at the beginning of the
year A lot of times they don't even know
that that's what they're signing off
for um so that is accept for a few
things um title 10 requires so this is
standard across the entire country it
says that every child over the age of 12
has to be allowed access to birth
control and uh Addiction Services
without parental consent so if you have
a school-based health clinic your child
can go and get those things over the age
of 12 without parental consent and then
uh New Hampshire laot in addition to
that requires that they have access to
SCD uh testing and treatment without
parental consent so those are the things
that in New Hampshire a child could go
to a school-based health clinic and get
done without their parental consent now
if you could wrap up okay um so last
year mistakes do happen last year there
were two children who got vaccinated
against their parents will right those
were mistakes because in you know
parental consent is
required but I know parents who will not
send their children to school on vaccine
clinic days because they're afraid of
mistakes if we allow school-based health
clinics to take hold every day is is
vaccine clinic day where there is a risk
for uh mistakes so um yes I will take
any questions but please support um HB
361 any questions represent McDonald
thank you Mr chair and thank you um you
mentioned that under New Hampshire law I
believe you said age 12 felt parental
consent for both birth control and a
number of other things and previous
speakers mentioned the birth control
implant you mentioned minor surgeries
would be allowed so under current New
Hampshire Law Without this bill would
say a young girl be able to go into one
of these clinics and get a birth control
implant without parental consent as
young as age 12 yes and and an IUD um
and that is already the case they could
go off to another doctor and get that
done without parental consent but there
is a certain limiting factor of
typically a child the age of 12 probably
needs somebody to drive them right so
there's a little bit of Parental
involvement this is unfettered access
because it's in the room next to their
classroom wow thank you further
questions
seen none thank you very much thank
you Amry
Banfield okay
so Melissa pretty much covered a lot of
what I was going to do um what I was
going to say so good I don't have to
repeat it this is kind of like your
child walk oh sorry Amry Banfield for
the record it's like your child going
out the Urgent Care and getting medical
services and you're not with them most
parents would never do something like
that but I think when you when you make
it the norm ins side of school we're
going to start seeing that that happen
um I went through the memorandum of
understanding with Manchester and amamos
and I found numerous problems with it as
as just
anybody looking for problems would have
probably found them um
for instance uh and I I will give you
all this and then I can also send you
the memorandum of understanding so you
can connect it so AMS geg is responsible
for the confidenti confidentiality and
security of all student data and must
notify MSD immediately upon any breach
of security there's no provision for
telling
parents once again parents are the last
to find out um and maybe they will tell
parents but it's not in the memorandum
of understanding
so there's a reference to the multi-tier
system of support for Behavior we
already know that third parties will not
give me information on what they're
doing um and in basic information on if
they're even billing Medicaid or
insurance I can't get that from some of
the uh some of the requests that I've
made to third party um
organizations and they a lot of times
when Federal money is funding this you
have to report back to the Fed so there
has to be reports that go back to the
federal government there a lot of this
money is coming from the federal
government so they're going to have to
come up with reports to report back as
we know that has been done with um Keen
state with mtssb and Keen state was uh
I'm sorry there were people pressuring
the school counselors to give personal
mental health information on student to
Keen state to develop their report that
information was given to me by a school
counselor I believe to the chairman and
I believe to the Comm
commer amamos Health may have access to
protected student information due to its
legitimate educational interest they
cannot perform their services without
access to the student data there is the
fle loophole so once again their citing
this information is protected but if you
understand the student Protection Law
there are exceptions so now somebody
from the outside can access this
information people people that nurse
practitioners doctors whoever helping
these children this now is information
you know if you're taking your do your
child to a doctor you know that all that
information is staying there for
depending on what they have to to reveal
to your insurance this is another
medical facility so there so there are
ways that information can be shared
without parental consent if you could
wrap up Miss oh boy I've got a whole lot
to go over but you know what why don't I
just send this to you um let see if I
can if there's everything oh yeah so you
know I do find an I mean my daughter's a
nurse practitioner so her reaction to
this was quite shocking because she's
worked in Pediatrics before so she's
worked with the actual doctors of
children that have come into the
hospital and that
communication issue is what she thought
that's going to be a problem they're
going to see somebody completely
separate from their doctor without their
parent there how are they getting all of
the background medical information on
that child to service that child maybe
give them um medication something like
that if they're coming in with di if
they're diabetic they're coming in with
any kind of medical issues that the
child may not share you know kids don't
necessarily say oh by the way I have
this genetic flaw in my family thank you
very much okay I'll I'll email it to you
thank you any questions see none thank
you
uh Dr
York Gary York from hopkington New
Hampshire uh chairman and members of the
committee uh I must admit a fair amount
of ignorance about this whole concept of
medical clinics in a school system it it
seems outrageous uh at the
outset um I I imagine that we would be
looking at maybe Dartmouth Hitchcock
Clinic Hopkinson high school or or or
conquered Hospital uh satellite Clinic
some such thing I'm not really sure
um I consider myself a strong proponent
of medical freedoms including but not
limited to Reproductive Rights job
mandates masking Medical Aid and dying
Etc uh I think that is something that
New Hampshire citizens should be
entitled to however having said that I
am not in favor of such medical freedoms
for students minors less than 18 years
old uh to me this is
just another attempt from evil sources
to rest control from parents regarding
health care decisions for their
children another concern I have is
that should there be such a
medical uh complex or Annex within a
school system the very proximity to this
uh to students is scary because as you
all know having been there in high
school the amount of PE pressure that
exists in school today uh you might have
a situation where uh because this is in
the school uh maybe the the high school
basketball team or the middle school
cheerleaders are pressuring each other
to get a a a new jab or something like
that so the very fact that it's a
concept that would be proximal to so
many
students uh whether it be Community
Health Clinic for the whole
Community um nonetheless that it's so
close is scary as a physician I worry
about the oversight for something like
that uh so yes it is a proactive uh bill
for sure and I don't
know what these things look like but I
think we need such a a bill in place to
sort of avoid any attempts to have these
health clinics infiltrate our school
systems
thank you thank you very much any
questions for the doctor see none thank
you ran
chest thank you committee chair thank
you committee members my name is russan
Chester I'm from Bedford New Hampshire
um as I had said previously I have a
long history of abuse and neglect
working with children uh but I'm going
to tell you a personal story more than
10 years ago my
stepdaughter was provided with a pelvic
exam and provided with birth control in
Middle School it was because my child
has a history my my stepchild had a
history of abuse and neglect significant
abuse and neglect from when she was a
small
child we chose to move to the school
district we did because she wanted a
fresh start she didn't want everyone
knowing her history so when we moved to
that new school district we didn't tell
everybody what we as parents were doing
she was going to counseling three days a
week and when it came time for sex
education in the classroom the note came
home and I encouraged her not to do the
classes because I was worried about her
trauma history she wanted to be be a
normal kid and she asked to go through
those
classes I agreed under the under the
agreement that she would come home every
day and talk to me about those classes
about 2 weeks into the classes she shut
down on me I went to the school
counselor and I said what's going on I
don't understand she has completely
she's like a different child she's
depressed she's anxious she's she's say
saying that everything's going fine but
clearly it's not going
fine staff at the school
assumed that my daughter was being
abused by her father and myself not that
this was what they call
transference now this was a school
counselor school counselors are not
appropriately prepared to understand the
significance between the find the whole
child and although this is medical it is
also they put my child on birth control
without parental knowledge or consent
and they did that because it it was a
risk to the child if if because the
parents might be causing this abuse and
neglect so and in the state of New
Hampshire that's the way it works if you
if the teacher says teacher School staff
says I the child is reporting that she
is afraid to tell the truth to the
parents that is the ability for the
school to say well we didn't have to
tell you because we were afraid of the
consequences these child health clinics
are dangerous I worked in a child health
clinic and I can honestly say it is not
appropriate for it to be taking place in
the school without parental rights in
place thank you any
questions see none thank you very
much uh Nancy
Peterman she left okay thank you very
much in that case we'll close the
hearing on House Bill
360 yeah we'll take a uh couple of
minute break um while we get ready for
the next hearing which is house bill 50
um
I
e
e e
going to open the hearing on host Bill
50 relative to teaching discrimination
in public schools and discrimination in
public workplaces and I welcome the
prime sponsor representative petrigno
thank you thank you madam chair and
members of the committee for the Recon
representative Peter patrino from the
town of Milford and I'm here in yet
another attempt at repealing the law
titled the right to freedom from
discrimination in the workplace and
education mindful that I have been
unsuccessful in the past but as a matter
of principle I decided to file it once
again as a former social studies teacher
and department head I dedicated my
entire adult life to education and
attempted to create classroom lessons
which were relevant Dynamic and
inspiring that hopefully encouraged my
students to become lifelong Learners and
independent thinkers and I truly see
this law as an obstacle to that that it
stifles meaningful education and I also
believe that I speak for the vast
majority of teachers in this
regard social studies is not about
simply memorizing facts in civics
economics geography and history it's
about guiding students and utilizing
their knowledge to develop critical
thinking skills leading them to form
well-reasoned objective opinions about
the world they live in so they can
become thoughtful and engaging citizens
now at meramac high school we attempted
to meet these objectives by developing
competencies around research skills
content knowledge critical analysis and
objective
evaluations one engage in activity was
for the students to make their own
personal predictions about America's
future utilizing comparisons in
contrasts to that of the Roman Empire
now aside from any factual errors there
were no right or wrong answers to their
conclusions however it was a
demonstration of the students critical
analysis and well reasoned opinions
using their knowledge of both current
events and historical facts so it's true
that the current law allows for the
teaching of history but it makes it
extremely difficult when trying to
examine the past and the context of some
of today's issues as I just described so
for example for many years the Roman
Empire struggled with massive migrations
from Germanic tribes along their
Northern borders they built walls they
deployed border patrols they engaged in
military clashes so can a classroom
discussion ensue that makes parallels to
today's migration crossings from the
Mexican border especially as some frame
the issue within a racial context now
that would be a thoughtful and engaging
classroom discussion but teachers worry
can they even go there so finally in
every Walk of Life you're going to find
examples of those who conduct themselves
inappropriately
unprofessionally but you do not address
the improper behaviors of some by making
it difficult for everyone to do their
jobs
education is about
teaching opening Minds
indoctrination is about preaching and
controlling Minds those in the classroom
who do not know the difference need to
be set straight but this law is not the
answer thank you very much for listening
to my testimony I'll be happy to take
any questions thank you any
questions representa cel thank you um
can you would you be willing to share
some examples of ways in which some
teachers may have expressed their
feelings of being by by the current law
being incapable of teaching some of
these things could you elaborate on that
a little bit certainly uh there have
been a number of instances you take a
look at some of the uh current events uh
that we're uh engaging uh with you just
go online and you see words like uh
Nazis and fascism uh socialism uh just
thrown about willy-nilly
young people are on social media are
reading all of this and they have
questions so in the classroom you know
you study the past why just for Trivial
Pursuit no you study the past so you can
understand what's going on today make
those connections and maybe kind of make
the world a better place in the future
so you examine uh the Civil Rights
Movement for example and can you talk
about uh today's um uh White
supremacists you know or if you talk
about the Holocaust do you just leave it
in the past and never ever discuss um
today's neo-nazis because as soon as you
bring that up a teacher is like oh well
we can't go there so what we're going to
do is we're just going to talk about the
past and we'll just fill you ahe with a
lot of facts so you can go on a Jeopardy
and and win some big prizes and that's
not what education's about there's a
reason why we we teach and it's to
enable individuals to be thoughtful and
engaging individuals so we can have
debates and discussions just like we do
right here in committee room you know I
like to think that all of us come from a
place of some knowledge we think about
it and then we present our opinions I
used to say to my students I would joke
at them they'd say well this is how I
feel this is what I think and I say you
know I I really don't care what you feel
and what you think and they look at me
well that's that's my opinion like okay
wait a second if you can present that
argument in a way that has some facts
behind it I might be go okay okay but
then maybe I'll push back a little bit
and give you some other things to think
about you see it's about putting
thoughts in your head and thinking and
examining so you can come to a place
where your view is objective right now
we're living in a world where people
like on both sides and nobody really
wants to think about and bring us to to
a place somewhere in the middle I don't
know I'm elaborating too much here but
you can tell I'm very passionate about
this but those are some
examples and any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much all right thank you very much and
and thank you for all you do because to
be honest with you you guys spend a lot
of time in this committee thank
you The Honorable Arlene
corello hello again uh thank you madam
chair members of the education committee
um I had initially planned to come up
here today for the The Mask Bell that I
previously spoke on for which I had
prepared comments um this for this one
I'm going to just speak from the heart
um when I left my seventh grade class
today uh in the middle of class to come
up here um I left a video playing for
them it was the uh second episode of a
documentary series called the
abolitionists and it featured Frederick
Douglas
and um I just thought that was sort of
coincidental that now we're talking
about this bill I remember a couple of
years ago when this was
um it was beginning of my term when it
was brought up we filled rep's Hall
with dozens and dozens of teachers who
said they
were they were they felt um afraid to
teach certain subjects because they
would be fired and um it included
subjects of both the historical and
current nature and
um I just was sort of baffled because
some people might even be afraid to
teach The Narrative of the Life of
Frederick Douglas an American slave
which I've always taught even when I
taught College freshman I I used it and
now my sixth and seventh graders are
reading it which is why I had them watch
a little video first um what this
bill
basically wants to do is is take away
the
um it wants to repeal the law that
prohibits teachers from teaching
students that certain groups of people
are inherently Superior or inferior if
you read to the original Law this this
is a bill to repeal that um supporters
of this bill object to the existing law
they complain that it discourages
teachers from covering certain
historical topics as I
said um
what the current law basically says is
that you know teachers
can can teach that slave owners abuse
slaves I mean I left my students
watching this video where there was qu I
had to give them a little trigger
warning and say there's a really uh
graphic scene of this um so um we can
teach about the horrors of the
institution of
slavery we can't insinuate that students
in their classrooms um that that that
belong to a particular raal group should
somehow feel guilt and shame over these
events of the past that were in no
remote way their
fault um because that that is what's
happening i' I've heard anecdotes and I
didn't again didn't prepare my remarks
so I can't tell you specific ones but
you know this this does happen sometimes
where children will come home from
school and and tell their parents that
they were upset because they were made
to feel that they were somehow um bad or
or something um I'm just going to close
with something I have my book here at
the that's one of the reasons I I had in
my bed when I left work um the thing
about Frederick Douglas with a chapter
that I find really inspiring because
that's why we teach this to inspire okay
it's not just history um this is
teaching you how how to to treat people
um Frederick Douglas had a a a mistress
who was taught him how to read and write
and she was very he describes her as
kind tenderhearted woman um all sorts of
very just Angelic woman and then
suddenly she Chang and she wouldn't
teach him how to read and write anymore
and what he said was that slavery proved
as injurious to her as it did to me he
blamed the institution of slavery on her
change but that she was an inherently
good woman a good person and and that's
what we need to teach the children is
that people are inherent actually
reminds me of an Frank who said that I
believe that most people are inherently
good um you know so anyway that's why I
think it is so important that we keep
the the law that we have um so that it
um we can prevent the the issues that I
raised here so um I would hope that you
would vote itl on this bill so thank you
any
questions seeing none good to see
you Aubrey fredman
need to change that just
changeing uh Madam chair committee
members Aubrey fredman I live in
Bridgewater now this one I'm going to
oppose
so okay RSA
19340 section 2 this is currently the
law it's very clear in this
section but it's saying nothing in this
I'm quoting nothing in this section
shall be conscrew to prohib it
discussing again it says discussing as
part of a larger course of academic
instruction the
historical uh existence of ideas and
subjects identified in this section so
when PE teachers say well we can't teach
this stuff you can discuss it I mean you
can talk about redlining slavery 1619
project Stonewall Riot I mean any number
of things that
uh are kind of common Nazism whatever
there's many things you can white
supremacy you can discuss anything you
just can't promote it that's the
difference here
so
teachers they need to check their
politics at the front door and so when I
was reading this bill I was thinking
back to when I was in junior high and
high school thinking about like uh
social studies and history classes again
this is many many years ago I still
remember the teachers I don't really
recall if they were Republican or
Democrat conservative liberal communist
it just there I have no memory of that
and I remember them very clearly they
checked their politics at the door and
you really didn't they didn't push
anything they were free to discuss and
it's not any different but I do think
some not all teachers do have a certain
agenda that they are pushing in the
classrooms and that is wrong you cannot
just like any other employee they are
employees of the taxpayers you you have
to follow the rules you can't just teach
whatever you want and the law right now
says you can discuss things but you
cannot promote your Pol promoting racism
sexism victimhood these are evil things
to be promoting and you should be figh
as far as I'm concerned if you're
promoting them if you're just discussing
them that's good that's what a teacher
does so group think is bad and I think
it's especially bad for teachers to be
uh we should be promoting individuals
the rights of individuals uh we're not
mindless cogs in a in a tribe we are all
individuals and that's what and if
actually teachers are really interested
in helping uh the ones in protective
classes we should be raising the
academic standards that will actually
help them the most rather than pushing
politics so that's why I oppose this
Bill thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you attorney hwit
thank you Madame chair and members of
the committee Ian huitt appearing for
Cornerstone in opposition I really
enjoyed uh representative petrino's
testimony in large part because as the
saying goes I think about the Roman
Empire every day I like studying Roman
history and thinking about it I like
thinking about parallels between
American history and Roman history I
like talking about it and I noticed
though that I've always managed to do
that without ever saying that any group
of people should face discrimination
because of their race or that any group
of people is inherently privileged or
racist because of their race and so I
think that it should be easy for
teachers to make that distinction as
well I think there is often kind of a
mod and Bailey that goes on around this
bill because if you take a look at judge
barbadoro injunction saying that this
law can cannot be enforced at no point
does Judge barbadoro say the problem
with this law is it will prohibit
teaching about ancient Germanic
migration he does not say the problem is
it will prohibit teaching about the
Holocaust he says the problem looking at
page 27 of the U opinion letter is that
this may deter teachers from teaching
about the benefits of affirmative action
and he goes on to talk about how
affirmative action is important because
it remedies past discrimination and
promotes
diversity so as I move between as I
often do legislative advocacy and
constitutional litigation which I often
do I often see on contentious issues
like this certain groups will make very
different arguments to bodies like this
one that they will make in front of a
judge and in this case I notice that
often the argument before legislative
committees is this is deterring us from
teaching about the Holocaust and yet in
court the argument is we want to teach
that affirmative action is beneficial
AKA that white students should face
discrimination and so I think if the
judge can tell what this law is
prohibiting well enough to say that's
precisely why I'm going to enjoin it
because I object to that prohibition
then teachers also really can tell what
it's prohibiting and not prohibiting now
potentially the current law could be
amended to overcome the current
injunction but I think ultimately
politically everyone really does does
understand what this law prohibits and
litigation like this litigation shows
that I would be happy to answer any
legal questions uh Madam chair I do
school and other first amendment
litigation so I'd love to take any
questions about the constitutionality of
this law or its enforcement mechanism or
anything of that kind thank you any
questions representative celik thank you
I just um you said you represent
Cornerstone correct can you clarify what
Cornerstone is please Cornerstone is New
Hampshire's full-time Christian advocacy
organization we represent over 100
churches of different Christian
denominations around the
state any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you madam
chair andry
bamfield good afternoon again for the
record AMR BFI parental rights
Advocate um I don't support the bill e
there I um I I do think that there's
other things that we can be doing to
help um improve on some of these
subjects that I'm going to bring up uh
RSA 193 col 40 addresses a worldview
that has been permeating some public
schools for several years now and this
worldview has been described as critical
race Theory but I think a better
accurate term would be called a
anti-racism
and 193 col 40 appears to be restricting
schools from teaching or requiring
students to adhere to a specific world
view anti-racists PE PE um place people
into two different categories one
category includes people who are
inherently Su Superior and the other to
the other category of people children
are being coached in the anti-racist
world view K to2 in some K to2
classrooms so where does this world view
come from and where have we seen it in
the public schools in New Hampshire in
sau6 administrators spent
$20,000 on a book called this book is
anti-racist and this book was purchased
for middle school
students the self-described ards you go
through the social study standards and
you make sure that what is required to
be taught in the classroom is included
in those standards we can do that as a
state you can go to the commissioner you
can go to the State Board of Education
and make that requirement of them that
is exactly what they did in Florida they
added African American history standards
to their academic standards and if you
go through them 20 Pages which I went
through and read them I think everybody
in this room might learn something maybe
the social studies teachers would not
but I think everybody would learn
something from they're very good um one
of the standards says Identify American
a Americans African-Americans who
demonstrated heroism patriotism wouldn't
that be a nice thing to learn so they
bring up you know they give examples tus
skiggy Airman Martin Luther King Jr Rosa
Parks uh one says describe the history
and evolution of slave codes I suspect
that our kids aren't learning this a lot
of this in in school and we do have an
Avenue to do that so th those are just
my suggestions
um work on the standards and include
various viewpoints in the school thank
you very much any
questions I see none thank you very much
thank you uh ran
Chester thank you committee chair thank
you committee members Russ anchester
Bedford New Hampshire um I am running
for a school board in my town and I had
the opportunity to meet with the
superintendent of schools because I'm
truly interested in being the best
school board member that I can be
during that interview um he identified
the perfect Schoolboard member as
someone that does their homework and is
open-minded to look at why one side
would support a position and the other
side would support a direct opposite
position and use your critical thinking
skills to come up what's truly in the
best interest of the children what's
interesting is when you walk into a
classroom and you see a specific flag as
an adult there's all kinds of things
going on in your mind is that flag there
because they're an ally is that flag
there because they identify etc etc okay
children developmentally are not in a
place to try to do that so bringing that
into the classroom can be problematic
what's really interesting for our
teachers is that if teachers are worried
about um teaching something and being
accused of being racist or LGBT TQ plus
Ally or whatever um what's really
interesting is artificial um
intelligence does a great job explaining
what is and what is not CRT what is and
what is not seal what is and what is not
Dei and what's really interesting is all
three of those started during the Civil
Revolution the Civil Rights revolution
in closing the bottom line is
discrimination is discrimination the
bill that's in place now does protect
that and our children we should not be
worried about a protective class
shouldn't all our children be
protected thank you very much any
questions R Woodcock than just a quick
summary I couldn't figure out if you're
for or against the bill I am opposed to
this Bill thank
you thank you very
much Vanessa bla
good afternoon thank you Mr chair
members of the committee my name is
Vanessa blae I serve as the deputy of
I'm sorry I serve as the Director of
policy and planning for the New
Hampshire Council on developmental
disabilities um unfortunately our
executive director could not be here
today um so she asked me to um read her
letter into record
dear chairman cordelli and members of
the House Education policy and
administration committee my name is
isidora Rodriguez Leandra and I am the
executive director of the New Hampshire
Council on developmental disabilities
known as the DD Council I am providing
testimony on behalf of the DD Council
membership which believes that hb50
would have a positive impact on the
disability
Community as a disability advocacy group
we believe that it is important to
prevent discrimination on the basis of
race sex age gender identity Creed
marital status religion national origin
and mental and physical
disability disability is a natural part
of human diversity and it is also a
natural part of the human experience and
we need to challenge stereotypes and
biases about their abilities and their
contributions persons who experience
disability face many barriers daily
whether they are physical attitudinal or
systemic barriers to community inclusion
integration and
participation ableism which is
discrimination based on disability is a
societal attitude teaching people to
believe that people with disabilities
are less than or deficient in some way
to combat ableism we must be able to use
the real life examples and experiences
of groups of people who have
historically faced discrimination in
education and employment including
disabled
people public schools and workplaces
have a foundational importance in
identifying policies practices and
barriers that are ablest in nature they
often serve as a front line in
advocating and educating our community
on how to be more inclusive and
accommodating towards disabled people
cultural competence includes awareness
and intentional design to include people
with disabilities but this can only
happen if people are taught about
discrimination and depression to correct
and prevent it in the future studying
disability is studying culture teaching
disability history is integral to
empowering the Next Generation to
understand their roots and current
issues that impact their
Futures teaching disability history is
Paramount to Civic engagement currently
one in four adults has a disability in
the United States disability history is
interwoven into all aspects of History
it's important for students to
understand what was like what life was
like for people before these protections
were passed and how these protections
impact themselves and their
peers our Council by law is comprised of
at least 60% of people with
developmental disabilities and parents
and guardians of people with
developmental disabilities these members
are volunteers advocating for disability
access and inclusion this involves
advocating for public policies and
initiatives that remove barriers and
create opportunities in all areas of
life for people with
disabilities please feel free to reach
out with to us with any questions about
how this would have a positive impact on
Children and Families impacted by
disabilities thank you thank you very
much and if um you'd be so kind as to
turn in the written testimony um to one
of our members will'll get it entered
into the record great thank you and I
think that that is the last card we have
um we'll close the hearing on House Bill
50 thank you everybody and we're going
to reopen our executive session for uh a
moment um I would like to take up House
Bill 362 we discussed it briefly um and
uh we're comparing that with House Bill
440 and um I did have conversation with
the Department of
education and um Mr applebe thought that
the language in House Bill 440 which we
uh did pass yesterday I guess it seems
like a long time ago um would eliminate
the need for the
waiver um I have not heard back from Mr
beard but I assume that since Mr um
applebe um is in agreement on 440 as was
Mr feed um we can go with House Bill 440
so I will move that we retain House Bill
362 um in the event that
um uh multiple people in Department get
together and have multiple opinions and
we still have house build
362 and um if no further need um is
found later on the beginning of the year
we can just itl 362
um
so I should turn over the
Cav yeah I'm
sorry I guess we'll open this executive
session on HB 362 and I Look to
representative cordelli for a motion uh
I move um to retain House Bill 362 I'll
second representative SEL
seconds any more
discussion see
none you ready to go I'm ready okay uh
the motion before us is to retain uh
Vice chair
Noble yes and see who's actually here
today represented McDonald yes clerk
votes yes representative Morris yes
representative NATO yes representative
Cornell yes representative Murray yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
cig yes and representative snug
yes
Y and Cher Celli yes sorry about that uh
total 12 years
Z great and so that um finishes that
bill doesn't go to the floor no
reports um so with that I think we are
uh finished for today and um for the
next well we have we'll see you all
tomorrow but then we have a we'll have a
week off